Hey everybody,
what's up?
This episode of the showings parents
podcast is brought to you by stamps.com.
You've probably heard,
but the cost of a stamp just went up to
forty nine cents and by the way,
if you're complaining about a stamp
being forty nine cents,
you're a Douche bag.
It's only forty nine cents.
Imagine if I had to give you money to
take a fucking letter across the
country.
I think you'd want more than forty nine
cents.
It's an awesome bargain,
but let's be honest.
Go into the post office.
Sucks the fat Dick.
We all know what does.
It's slow.
It's not efficient,
it's boring.
It's fucking boring.
My mom sent me a letter that had the
wrong postage on it and it went all the
way to Burbank and then the burbank post
office.
It's like,
Hey,
this doesn't have enough postage on it
and send it back.
Oh Jill,
genius.
Fucking brilliant.
The real issue is if you have a small
business,
if you have a small business,
if you send things through the mail,
that's a place where a service like
stamps.com
is invaluable because with stamps.com
does is it allows you to print us
postage on a regular home computer,
regular printer,
just print it out,
stick it on packages,
mailman comes,
hand it to him,
done.
They give you a digital scale with the
free j r e $110 bonus offer,
and this free digital scale allows you
to measure mushrooms.
Well,
no,
don't do that.
It's not what I meant allows you to
measure your packages.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
As your packages and print up actual us
postage on your computer and then just
send it off.
It's genius.
It's really a beautiful way to save a
lot of time,
especially if you send things on a
regular basis,
especially if they're varying weights.
Oh my goodness.
That is annoying.
You know,
it's annoying and I know it's annoying.
This is an easy way to work around that.
Stamps.com
always keeps their rates up to date.
So you'll always get the exact postage
you need every time right from your
desk,
even if the government changes the rate,
which I think they're entitled to.
Forty nine cents,
Jesus people really complaining about
that anyway.
Right now,
use my Promo Code J r e for this special
offer.
No risk trial plus $110 bonus offer,
including a digital scale up to $55 or
free postage.
So go to stamps.com.
Before you do anything,
click on the old school,
the microphone and the right hand corner
and type inj r e that stamps.com.
J R e,
it is used by us by our friends.
It's used by Thompson [inaudible],
Christina Palicki,
whose podcast I'll be on next week.
Your mom's house next Tuesday.
I'll be on it.
They're awesome.
And they use stamps.com
to send their shit.
Burst.
Burke crush uses it to send his shit.
Brian Red band uses it for all the desk
[inaudible] dot TV kitty cat shirts.
So it's an awesome service.
We like it,
we love it.
And you will to use a cohert.
Jerry were also brought to you by
[inaudible] dot com.
That's o n I t o n n let me say it again
on it,
o n n I t if you've heard this podcast,
he probably heard noncommercial and
there's way for me to do them any other
way.
This is,
this is what it is,
what we sell it on.
It is everything that I use,
everything that arbor uses,
everything that we find out about that
is beneficial to either physical
fitness,
beneficial to cognitive function,
healthy snacks like hemp,
hemp force protein bars or Tonka,
buffalo bars which are made the old
school way,
the same way,
uh,
of the native Americans used to make
them.
So actually buffaloes and cranberries
and shit.
They're delicious.
And it's not bad for you man.
It's a,
it's actually an interesting t to eat.
No MSG,
no soy,
no lactose,
which has tried to sell cool shit.
Hemp force protein powder.
Um,
whether it's um,
cognitive enhancement supplements like
Alpha brain or new mood,
which by the way,
Alpha brain,
we released the results of the first
clinical trial.
Very positive,
especially in two areas and execution
and memory and all the results are
available online.
You could find them on the Alpha brain
page and we're in the middle of a much
larger study.
Now.
That study was actually a,
um,
what they call it,
pilot study.
They do a study of say like 16 to 20.
Well I guess it was 20 people initially
and I think it got down to 17 or 16 and
what happens is some people just quit,
you know,
people are fucking flaky,
but the pilot study is to make sure that
the protocol is a adequate,
you know,
we decided to go with a two pills per
person.
I take four before I do things,
but I'm a fucking maniac folks.
That's just what I do.
I'm crazy like that.
And on a one 80 actually has alpha brain
in it,
a little bit of new mood as well.
Some five htp and on a one 80 is
fantastic for me.
For anytime I fly somewhere I just
immediately take that upon landing.
Anytime I feel like I have jetlag,
anytime I'm boozing it up,
which I,
I really don't do anymore.
I gave out boozing it up with me.
I still get high,
but uh,
I just,
I just don't.
The rec afterwards just sucks so hard,
man.
I've been doing the same thing.
Yeah.
Uh,
I try to limit it to two drinks.
If I go out a lot of times I don't even
have the desire to have more than one
because why do that?
When you can do other things that are
better and don't give you a hangover?
Exactly.
The other night I had to and it was
crazy.
I had a glass of wine with dinner and
then I was out with some friends and I
had a jack and coke.
I was nuts.
It was a very mild jack and coke though
a point being the,
the issues that you deal with when you
are hung over.
There's a bunch,
there's dehydration,
but there's also a depletion depletion
of all the beautiful things that make
your mind rich and interesting.
Like Serotonin,
you know,
you fucked up from alcohol man,
and you get fucked up from the lack of
sleep.
You don't get good sleep when you'd go
to bed drunk.
I mean you're just a mess.
All the ingredients in Alpha brain and
all the ingredients in one a or any of
the other supplements that we have are
available at [inaudible] dot com,
along with all of the scientific
research and references that point to
individual
studies about individual ingredients and
the most recent study on Alpha brain,
which is the study on the actual
combination of the ingredients to
achieve a synergistic effect.
There's a lot of science behind it,
but there's also a lot of controversy.
So to alleviate some of the concern at
Onnit,
we offer a 90 day 30 pill,
100 percent money back guarantee.
So if you buy a bottle of Alpha brain 30
pills,
you have 90 days to tell us it's
bullshit.
And if you don't like it,
I look,
I have no idea how your brain works.
Uh,
I know for me it's not just beneficial,
it's essential.
I love the shit.
I feel nervous if I do a UFC without it.
I really do.
I.
I think that it helps me form sentences
better as I form a shitty sentence.
It helps me when I'm searching for
words,
I get them easier and I know that sounds
weird,
but go on at.com.
O n n I t used the Codeword Rogan save
10 percent off any and all supplemental.
Alright.
Boom.
Cello clock.
David Seaman is here and we're fixing a
busy.
We've got a lot of shit to talk about.
Hitting the bitcoin fan.
It is.
Shit's crazy.
Fair.
The Joe Rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcasts all day.
Fitting that our friend David Seaman is
here the very day that Mt.
Gox the big storage place or whatever
the fuck it is.
This site,
the,
it's an online exchange for bitcoin.
The exchange is diggity.
Diggity done.
Yeah.
So it hit the wall.
I'm like the forrest gump kind of random
trends.
Like I'm always kind of in the
background of all this completely
unrelated shit and yeah,
Mt.
Gox was run by this guy who is a,
uh,
allegedly kind of a,
a piece of shit I got to say like
allegedly is you guys do.
But as a respectable journalists,
I've heard sources say he's a piece of
shit.
And uh,
so there is an error in the way that his
site interacts with the overall bitcoin
network and the same way that if you,
you know,
are using email and you happen to
download a shitty email program,
like a knockoff version of outlook and
it fucks up the way you send your
emails.
It doesn't mean there's a problem with
email.
There's a problem with what you're using
and the way you've implemented it.
And email has been used enough by now
that we know that it works.
And it was kind of a similar issue here
where there was an incompetent
implementation and some hackers were
able to steal over time,
somewhere between $300,
million to $400,000,000
worth of bitcoin.
So it's pretty brutal.
And bitcoins taking a bashing in the
press,
which is well deserved.
But uh,
I personally bought more or less night
because I've just been reading about it
so much that I actually kind of believe
it and I'm drinking the Koolaid and in
that case when some shit like that
happens,
it's not a tragedy,
it's actually kind of an opportunity
because I'm like,
well now I can actually buy some more
this instead of only having a little bit
of the future currency of the new world
order,
I'll have a real fraction of it and I'm
already getting shit from people who are
like,
you're promoting a product that is new
world order designed.
And I'm like,
do you have any evidence of that?
Like have you actually read even a 10th
as much of the people who were reporting
on this shit?
Like everything is out there about
bitcoin and yet they're already moving
towards.
It was created by two.
I think that's sort of what we were
talking about before the podcast
started,
that there's a bunch of people that love
for something to be a conspiracy.
So they look for it and everything in
anything,
things that are.
I've been involved in things where I
know there was no conspiracy.
I know I was there and yet I've had
people tell me that it was like ufc
fights,
like the things are fixed,
that someone wasn't really injured and
that they're just.
It's a big scam and all it is is to set
up another fight.
They had this all along shuffle.
It's like people love to think,
well,
it's because there are some
conspiracies,
so they go looking for him because they
don't want to be a fool.
Right?
Nobody wants to be fooled by them and
that that is the number one problem with
the fact that conspiracies have actually
existed.
They've muddied the water so badly.
It's sort of like a disinflation tactic.
It's like one of the things that I
always talk about,
like if you read anything about
intelligence and you read that not not
intelligence,
like human intelligence,
but intelligence reporting for the
government.
One of the things they do when they're
trying to control information is they
discredited by attaching it to
ridiculous shit.
It's just what they do.
Yeah.
It's actually like a an actual
strategies you mix in the bullshit with
the good stuff poisons the well and you
don't believe any of it.
Yeah.
It's like if you believe in something
absolutely ridiculous for long with some
really interesting shit,
they can automatically point to that
ridiculous thing and say,
let's say same guy believes that people
are reading your mind from a base on the
moon and then he goes,
that true.
Does he really believe that?
Well,
then you find out what's really going
on.
You find out that all this other stuff,
like if you ever read Bill Cooper,
no course,
I've heard of that book for some reason,
but you will.
You read it and you go,
wow,
this stuff's really fascinating.
And then he starts talking about alien
bases on the moon and you're like,
wait,
wait.
What?
Yeah,
started talking like that actress
Shirley Mcclain has a book,
has a book that I was skimming through.
That's all about like how in the 19
fifties the US government had a secret
meeting with like seven different
species of alien and there was this
council and even though she's a good
actress,
you reading this shit and you're like,
I can't believe anything you're saying
now because this is a little out there.
She's awake.
He wacky,
broad.
Have you ever heard her talk about look,
sidekicks and all kinds of other shit?
No,
I'm just skimming this book and it was
enough.
She's alone.
She's a full on loan,
but what?
But she could totally be right.
I want to add that and also I want to
believe she's right about the alien
council.
She's asleep.
Silly
person.
I mean you could,
you could Google shirleen mcclain and
find out all the different spiritual
healing energy things she's into and
yeah,
she's.
She's just an erotic massage probably.
She's The lady that you know,
like there's a thing that to humans,
and it's the same thing.
It happens to men and it happens for
women when they stopped being desirable
physically.
They often look to fantastical and
unimaginable things like Ufo shows or
fucking spiritual awakenings and psyche.
They look for something that drags them
out of the mundane existence of biology
because if the UFO was real,
if aliens were real,
if big foot was real,
if you could really read people's minds,
it wouldn't matter if no one wanted to
fuck you anymore.
Yeah.
There's something that's bigger than
yourself.
So this is a reason why like menopausal
women,
like older women get really into that
kind of shit.
Like if you look at like,
and I'm not saying that young women
don't get into it too.
They certainly do.
I would.
Men,
there are a lot of men,
a lot of men who are in the weird shit.
Fuck yeah.
I mean this is just one theory,
but there's,
there's a spiritual thing that happens
to a to a lot of older men and older
women where they,
they start looking for like,
you know,
paranormal things to start looking for.
Well,
they're starting to feel more spiritual
because they're getting toward that
point in life where you got to think
about that shit.
This is a little of that definitely,
but in the search for things and search
for things unseen,
like the search for big or search for
aliens,
I really do believe that a lot of what's
going on as if aliens were real.
It wouldn't matter if no one wanted to
fuck them and they're sleeping on a
friend's couch and they're 50.
It really wouldn't matter.
You know?
You guys don't know shit.
Let me tell you something,
but what the aliens they would get if
they just had a weed Brownie or maybe
like a weekend camping or something,
is that it already doesn't matter.
They don't need to find that other thing
to make their life seem like it's not a
big deal.
Just look up in the sky.
Sometimes nothing matters with
certainty.
There is some crazy article in
scientific American that if you were to
add up all the people who've ever lived
on earth,
it's like a $100 billion people.
Yeah,
so you just don't matter.
Period.
Like where were these fucking things
that are running around trying to spread
our,
our genetic code and then our hearts
filled with cholesterol and we die.
It's like some weird video game and so
somebody like that feels that they need
to find religion or they need to find
aliens in order to feel like they're a
part of things.
They're already a part of things so they
already don't matter.
So what more do you need?
It's like,
that's perfect right there.
I don't even think it's a don't matter
thing.
I think they're looking for something
exciting for a lot of people.
I mean obviously it's just one of these
goofy theories I'm chasing down,
but for a lot of people when it comes to
what matters in life,
one of the big things that matters in
life is being sexually desirable.
And when you stopped being sexually
desirable,
like unequivocably no argument,
no one wants to fuck you.
Right?
And it happens sooner to women than it
does men.
Because for a man you're like 18 or 20.
Nobody wants to fuck you because you
have nothing going on.
Start to get into your mid twenties.
If you're good looking,
you might be able to get something based
on that,
but as you get older you get more status
and more experience.
You know what the fuck you're talking
about more often.
That's where attraction comes from,
but for women it's like twenties.
You're fucking prime right there.
You're already at the Max and the 25 is
still good.
Still good,
but as you get older,
as society is not just heaping you a
heaping status upon you,
right?
It's still for you very much looks
based.
Whereas an older guy,
nobody cares what Richard Branson looks
like or what Felix Dennis looked like.
It's more about who they are,
but if some actresses in a show and she
looks old,
everybody will say that.
Yeah,
there's definitely something in that,
but I think like Richard Branson,
if he's got a really young hot wife and
that wife has got a personal trainer,
she's going to let him fuck her.
You think so?
I think so.
I think that guy would think that.
I think that trainer would end up on an
unsuccessful space flight.
Never come back.
I mean,
I don't think it's going to fuck her all
the time unless he's stupid,
you know,
you gotta make sure you don't turn into
a relationship.
But I think a lot of gold diggers,
they looked to fuck young guys for sure.
Some young studly broke bodybuilder type
dude with a giant hug because that's
what they really want
the end of the day.
They want the status,
but they also want something physical.
Oh,
women just want the money into sex and
that's all men want.
Also,
you know,
when I was young,
when I was a
again my,
uh,
my late teens and early twenties,
it was the most undesirable I've ever
been in my life.
Like I had the hardest time getting laid
the hardest because I was broke,
I was poor and I was,
you know,
it didn't even matter if I was
successful in some things like sports,
which I was,
it didn't matter because what was
important was money was important,
was financial success was important with
you not being a loser.
And I was a loser as far as like bank
accounts and as far as where I lived,
I was a loser and I was a young man.
And every young man's,
unless you're born rich,
you're starting out as a loser,
you don't have anything to show.
And women had no desire to be with me.
Zero.
There are guys who really kind of get
off on being able to bring women back
and have nothing going on.
We like,
look at what a loser I am and I'm still
getting laid.
So that kind of thing.
You can use that to your advantage
probably.
That's what I do.
When I was at colleges,
I was like,
yeah,
I'm a loser,
but if this is what I can pull now think
about 10 years from now when you're
actually not a loser,
how good things might be,
you know.
So that's a way to motivate yourself.
Well,
it also depends on what you're willing
to fuck to.
I mean,
everybody can get laid if you drop your
standards lower enough.
Women have the advantage in that area
because they can always get high quality
sex.
Whereas a guy like you really can't
unless you're at a certain stage in
life,
you can't just walk in somewhere and go
home with somebody that night,
but a woman can do that anywhere.
But the balance is that that's not what
most women want,
right?
They want different things,
relationships,
they want,
you know,
I think most women,
by the way,
this is just massive generalizations.
There's,
there's some women that just want to
fuck you and kick you right out the
door,
get out,
go by,
don't kiss me by.
I mean,
you know,
and that's fine too.
The,
uh,
the differences,
that guy laughs as he's getting out.
Okay.
You know?
Whereas if you do that to a girl,
like you're the worst piece of shit
ever.
If you fucked a girl and then after you
die,
like,
look,
you got to go.
Don't kiss me.
Go.
No,
no,
no hugs.
Yeah,
it's a real,
like a sociopath kind of thing to do.
Right?
But if a girl does it to a guy,
guy will go tell his friends,
dude,
she suck my Dick.
I fucked her.
Debbage kicked me out.
She had to go to work.
She came out,
she told me,
don't kiss her.
Listen,
this isn't going anywhere and get out.
I was like,
okay,
I'll call you if you want to fuck again.
Okay,
please do.
Thanks.
Yeah.
I think everybody's had that experience
where you're like,
I was just used and you're like,
wait a second.
So that's a bad.
Was awesome.
Totally different.
But I think it's totally different
because women have a different instinct
for the most part,
in a massive generalization,
by the way women have the instinct to
try to find a guy that they can trust,
try to,
you know,
spend unless you're done,
unless you've been through a few and
you're like,
well,
it's over.
It's what the Cougar thing is.
So people like about cougars,
the fucking given up.
I just like women who have their shit
together and cougars tend to be more
professional,
like executive types.
[inaudible],
I no longer go for the starving artist
because I always like to be the less
crazy person in the relationship and if
I'm the one that they're relying on for
some kind of stability and unlike
already completely fucking crazy with
the stuff I'm working on,
that's not a good thing.
You know,
like when somebody is asking me for
quarters to use the laundry machine,
it's not a good relationship.
So I'm more into the stability.
Yeah,
it's hard,
man.
It's hard when when you're dating,
you know,
in water,
the other is really financially
unstable.
It's,
it's always hard because it's very
stressful,
you know,
and it,
it,
it puts a giant wedge in the
relationship.
I have a friend,
she's successful and her boyfriend now,
ex boyfriend is.
I'm not very successful and one of the
things that they fight about is that
like he's just frustrated all the time.
He can't get anything going with his
career.
You actually,
it's funny that something just happened
for them.
Right.
As you know,
they broke up.
That always seems to happen.
There's like a,
sometimes a Murphy's law going on there
maybe,
but it's just,
you know,
we were talking about it and she was
talking about how difficult it is to
date someone who's really struggling
because it becomes a,
it's a mantra.
It's like going off in the back of the
head at all times.
Like you're broke,
you owe money,
your bills.
Oh yeah.
When you have money problems,
that's all you think about.
Collectors are calling you,
you're gonna,
you're gonna.
Get your car repossessed,
you need another job,
you need this,
you know,
and that it's just,
it's really hard to date someone like
that because you don't get them.
You get them under massive duress.
Right?
No.
Yeah.
It's definitely better if you can walk
into something where you have a bit of
money because when you have money,
it's the opposite feeling in your head,
oh,
this could go away if I wanted it to.
Whatever the problem is.
Like this could probably be reduced if I
need it to.
Well,
there's that for sure,
but this is the.
The big thing that I noticed when I got
my first development deal wasn't a lot
of money,
but it was enough money to where I could
relax.
Like I wasn't getting rich,
but it was like,
Holy Shit,
I've got some money,
like I can really.
I don't have to worry about paying my
bills.
I can pay my rent this month.
There was this crazy weight lifted off
my shoulder and I think I was 25 at the
time and you know,
most of my life up until that point,
from the time I was working,
it was all struggles.
Never.
There's no money in the bank.
The money was in the bank.
It was enough to pay whatever check I
sent out maybe,
and then I was going to have to stuff
some more money in there as quick as
possible to pay for the next bill's,
but all the sudden I had some money in
the bank and there was this weird
feeling of relaxation.
I was like,
wow,
this is incredible.
Not Rich.
Just not having to worry.
So whenever I give people,
you know,
if I talked to someone who's struggling
or talk,
someone's trying to plan the future,
I always say,
and this is,
it's hard to believe,
but it is the truth.
Being rich doesn't matter.
You get used to everything you're doing.
You get used to being in a big house.
I've been in a small apartment.
It felt exactly the same as being in a
big house.
Being in the big house is kind of cool,
but it's definitely not.
It's not worth what it costs to be in a
big house.
If you think like if you buy a house for
a million bucks,
the amount of money you have to spend
every fucking month on a million dollar
house and mortgage and fixing it up and
amount of hours that you have to work.
If you're,
you know,
you work a reasonable job,
you make 100 grand a year or something
like that.
Normal good wage.
It's a lot of fucking money,
man.
You,
your house cost 10 times what you make
in a year and you're never going to pay
it off in a year.
You're going to pay it off in 30 years
and then you're going to have to fucking
pay insurance on the fucking property
tax.
What do you mean property tax?
I got to pay tax on some shit I already
bought every year,
right?
Even I already own it.
I own the fucking house.
I own the property and I have to pay
you.
What am I paying you for?
I'm giving you money for what I own.
What the fuck is going on here?
And it'll drive you crazy and plumbing
and electricity and this and that.
When you really stop and think about how
much you're actually working for what
you're getting out of it,
it's definitely not worth it for most
people,
but what is worth it is to not worry
about going to dinner.
If you can have enough money where I can
go and get a meal at a restaurant and
not think too much about it,
just say I would like the salmon and not
look at the price and say the chickens
this much,
but the salmon's you know,
a dollar less.
I'll get the salmon instead of thinking
like that.
You can just order what you like.
You could go to a movie and not worry
about the movie.
All the other shit like the difference
between having a lexis and having a
Mercedes.
The difference between having a a Toyota
and having a Ford,
you get used to everything.
Everything you're doing,
you get used to,
as long as your car gets you to work,
it's fine.
If you have enough money to buy a
Mustang,
hey,
you love mustangs.
Go get a fucking Mustang,
man.
Enjoy yourself.
But if you don't,
don't sweat it.
Do you have a car that gets you there?
That's the real difference between your
car being repossessed.
You have no money for food,
you have no money for rent and being
able to pay your bills.
That's
the big jump.
The big jumps not for robberies and you
get used to that.
Still look at Steve Jobs.
He never went crazy and he was worth
billions.
There's always the fucking turtleneck
everyday,
but he did go crazy.
He went crazy to like to push success.
He went.
He never.
He didn't have a balanced perspective.
No,
but I mean in terms of he wasn't buying
a mansions and cars and stuff nonstop.
No,
but he was so obsessed with the pursuit
of,
you know,
apple being this dominant market player
and all the money that they made and
yeah,
he went a little crazy just in his own
way.
You know,
there's a minimalist crazy to where he
still lived in like the fucking silicon
valley where I have a friend who lives
up there.
They have a house that they're renting,
but the house was worth $50,
million dollars.
I want to tell you if that house was in
a fucking van eyes,
it wouldn't be worth 400 grand.
I was looking,
I was looking at a,
just a real estate website is San
Francisco.
There was a place for sale.
Those 200,000.
It looked like one of the shacks in
Detroit.
Just objective like a $10,000
property.
You're going for $200,000.
Oh,
no doubt.
If you could put another house in there,
eat.
If you could jam it in there with no
backyard.
Just fucking stuffing on the actual
footprint.
That areas where so much money,
when I say that it wouldn't be worth 400
grand event.
I'm probably exaggerating.
I would say it's probably worth a
million and van eyes.
It's a very nice house,
but my point is it's not a fucking 14,
$15,000,000
house or whatever the fuck they would
actually wind up getting for it.
It's just not,
but it's in this crazy area where all
these people have tech money and that
tech money,
squirrely money,
man.
It just.
The,
the,
the numbers are crazy.
It doesn't make any sense to find out
how much money.
Some of those guys.
I mean like the Google guys,
the facebook guys and you're like,
what?
Like that's crazy.
That's many yachts,
private jet Manchin,
buy an island money.
It's that insane.
What's going to get even crazier in the
years ahead with bitcoin because some of
the earliest adopters,
the amount of coins they have,
you think about it,
you're like,
well,
these people are for sure going to be
billionaires and they're going to be at
the upper end of that.
They're not even going to be like low
level billionaires.
Right?
But what would happen if they collected,
if they sold all their bitcoins?
Oh you can't,
you can't sell them all because then you
crash your own market,
you know?
But then what the fuck is the point in
having it?
I think for them eventually it's about
living in a world where you walk into a
store and the prices there and bitcoin
first.
So I think if they hold out for long
enough and if it doesn't get fucked over
by too much bad stuff like the Mt Gox
situation that we could live in a place
like that because then you have one
price regardless of what country you're
in,
you know,
kind of like a universal language.
It could really happen like it's kind of
a long shot,
but it could actually happen.
And in that case that person becomes
like science fiction rich,
you know,
like we're talking about somebody can be
worth hundreds of billions of dollars
instead of just worth,
you know,
10,000
bitcoins or whatever.
So science fiction rich.
So we kind of got off track.
How did this bitcoin collapse?
How this gox thing
take place?
What happened there already?
Conspiracy theories that Mt.
Gox was like some kind of CIA up to
discredit bitcoin really.
So that's what somebody tweeted me,
but I don't see any evidence of that.
Like it sounds like something they would
want to do if they thought of it in
advance,
but I don't think that's what happened.
I think it was purely incompetence.
This was a website that started like Mt.
Gox is short for magic.
The gathering online exchange.
Really it started as a place where
people sold magic cards.
No,
what not making this up.
This every.
They deserve everything that got this
company,
this company didn't know what the fuck
they were doing and didn't,
didn't know their ass from their elbow
in terms of programming languages.
Like somebody told me they programmed
their trading platform and PHP,
which I don't know that much about
programming that apparently is like
totally not the right language for
anything financial.
And their whole thing is based on this.
And uh,
so they're just super incompetent and
for whatever reason,
they're the ones who stumbled into this
massive market of like you're now
trading billions of dollars a bit coins
and supporting the whole planets,
you know,
Bitcoin,
a market and they weren't ready for
that.
And just series of fuck ups at every
stage of bad pr,
bad at communicating what's going on
when something doesn't work,
they just take it offline,
not realizing the implications of what
you're going to scare the shit out of
the whole market if you just take shit
off line and don't tell people in
advance.
And uh,
it looks like they got hacked by
somebody that somebody found an exploit,
took the money,
even though the money that was in cold
storage somehow,
which was supposed to be impossible,
but I'm sure they weren't competent
enough to have fucked up somewhere along
the way.
And now we're in the situation we're in
now where people are panicked.
But,
uh,
the good news is that there are other
exchanges out there that are much more
credible backed by real companies.
And they're coming online.
There are a couple in the US,
they're coming online,
which was pretty cool because I want to
see us be in on the action.
I don't want to see this be something
that's just happening in Japan and so
many places.
I'm sorry,
how did,
how did someone break in like how do you
get that money?
Like what do you,
what are you actually doing?
How are you getting that money?
Okay.
So yeah,
Bitcoin itself has not been hacked and
as far as I know,
it's never been hacked.
Like the actual protocol is 100 percent.
I don't want to say perfect,
but if I send you money,
there's certainty that I've sent it to
you.
And uh,
in this case they were using something
called transaction malleability,
which I,
full disclosure,
don't fully understand this shit,
but pretty much what I think it is is
like a,
if I write you a check,
you have to wait until that check clears
before you actually assume you have the
money.
And in this case Mt.
Gox was assuming based on unconfirmed
transactions that they had money or that
they were sending money.
And you apparently,
if you know anything about Bitcoin,
you can't do this.
And the other exchanges weren't doing
it.
And so it'd be like if you got a million
dollar check,
it could totally be a rubber check.
You don't know until it's actually
cleared.
You can't trade on that million dollars.
If bitcoin
really does become an emerging currency
that the whole world adopts.
What a great movie this is going to be.
Oh,
it's going to be amazing.
The Gathering Dorks stumble upon this
billion dollar.
You just see them sitting around.
He,
um,
we're worth a billion dollars.
Wouldn't it be cool if we had,
if we had girls and money and then they
switched over to bitcoin and seeing this
fat guy named Mark Karpeles is the CEO
of Mt.
Gox.
Is this him?
That is him.
What a fucking Dork.
He is.
Today's sorry buddy.
No,
I think that bitcoin is going.
He's hiding now.
They don't know his whereabouts.
So he's either hiding or probably being
tortured somewhere.
Who the fuck knows?
Oh my God.
Three hundred $50.
Million dollars because of this guys.
Fuck up.
It's a big fuck up.
Oh my God,
that's a big fuck up.
Can you imagine how many people want to
kill him?
That's real money to the $350,000,000
for folks that understand this.
This is not like people trading,
you know,
like fucking magic.
The gathering corns.
Yeah.
It's a liquid market.
You could buy $350,
million dollars worth of laptops if you
wanted to.
You could actually.
Tigerdirect is right,
but yeah,
and then also vegas casinos.
There's two casinos that are allowing
bitcoin.
There's many.
There's many emerging companies or we're
up into this pretty much every day on it
was even thinking about getting
involved.
They should.
I don't know about that.
This.
Well.
This is just going to be a blip on the
radar.
Oh,
I don't know how many blips this is.
Nonstop Bitcoin,
negative news.
I don't.
I think justice news alone is going to
make people not like invest or do
anything like maybe in the short term,
but I had the CEO of coin market on my
podcast the other day and he runs one of
the US exchanges.
They're actually based in Santa Monica
and he didn't sound phased at all.
He told me this is a couple of hours
before Mt.
Gox actually came out as being
insolvent.
He told me on the podcast,
I think they're insolvent and I think
they need to disappear as soon as
possible.
Not Disappears and run away,
but just like disappear from the bitcoin
ecosystem so that more credible
companies like us can step in and do
this shit in a way that's legal and
regulated and actually backed by real
investors.
And uh,
he didn't sound concerned about.
He's kind of like,
well,
yeah,
this are shitty competition is going out
of business and now we can take over.
And uh,
I wish I knew enough to know whether or
not he's correct.
That sounds very comforting if you're.
I think as long as people continue to
watch porn and like pay web cam,
girls with bitcoins,
as long as people continue to like
online gambling,
as long as you have libertarians who
want to stash away some of their money
in case there's some kind of financial
apocalypse,
as long as you have those three things,
there's always going to be bitcoin
demand.
That's a question.
You're not allowed to online gamble in
the US with money.
Can you online gamble with bitcoin
though?
I'm sure it's a highly gray area that
that would be a way to get bitcoin
rockin just tell people that they could
gamble in bitcoin.
Well,
there are casinos in Vegas now that have
started accepting too,
but I think that online it'd be online.
It's prohibitive
because the online,
a lack of online gambling is what
crushed the,
uh,
international pool league.
He had a,
uh,
this Kevin Trudeau,
you know,
that scam artists,
that guy.
Those are the secrets that they don't
want you to know about,
which is why I'm putting it in a book
for everybody to fucking read weight
loss secrets.
They don't want you to know about I just
people that are hiding information or
that guy put together this huge multiple
million dollar professional pool league
and he was going to market it based on
the idea that you could gamble on the
matches online and right when it was
coming out,
right when the invested all the money,
they changed the laws and it was just a
force out all the online gambling,
all the online casinos and online and
all that.
[inaudible] dot com,
all those different places to have.
Those guys all got fucked dudes had to
leave the country.
Like that bodog guy.
He had a boy dog fight.
There's an organization of fight
organization.
He had to leave the company,
the country.
You can't come to America if it comes to
America,
they'll arrest them and it's just
because of online gambling,
you know,
it's,
it's so gross.
It makes me so sick.
The idea that they can somehow another
prevent people from gambling,
but you don't prevent them from gambling
in Vegas,
you know,
prevent them in Atlantic city.
You don't prevent them.
An Indian casinos,
you don't prefer them in car casinos,
just like they've decided arbitrarily to
keep people from doing it online because
it hurts those casinos or hurts,
whatever.
Whoever it is that it hurts,
they've decided to allow them to
prohibit business.
They've allowed them to halt competition
and innovation because you're by
eliminating online gambling,
you're not just eliminating online
gambling,
you're eliminating a lot of different
financial transactions.
You're eliminating a lot of wagering
that is done through credit cards.
You're eliminating all sorts of
different things.
You're.
You're stopping a business.
You're stopping buildings from being
built.
You stopping people from being hired,
and it is freedom of expression.
If you're an adult and you're,
why shouldn't you be allowed to spend
your money on what you want?
Exactly.
You're going to force these people to go
to Costa Rica.
You,
I mean you're.
You're doing a lot of stupid shit.
You're,
you're really stopping business.
Everything from the construction of
buildings with these people,
we're gonna use to the employees,
the,
the financial careers that people could
have in online gambling,
running websites,
legit businesses.
Whether you're providing a legit
service,
but somehow or another this county
government got away with stopping all
that shit.
It's,
it really makes me sick.
But um,
if you could use bitcoin,
if,
if they could,
if that's a legal loophole and you could
use bitcoin to gamble on things.
God Damn like sports.
If you could gamble on the fucking super
bowl,
a major league baseball,
NBA,
UFC,
boxing,
golf.
If you could gamble on all that shit.
Yeah,
that'd be worth billions.
Fuck yeah.
It would be worth billions.
Not only would it be worth billions if
people found out that you could actually
buy shit with this bitcoin.
They would start investing chunks of
their portfolio in bitcoins and people
would say,
hey,
you know,
I want percent of my finances
in bitcoin because I like to gamble.
I think the whole porn thing is going to
be huge where a lot of guys want to know
where I want to tip the girls that they
watch on the live cam sites,
but they don't because they don't want
their credit card linked to the site
because then their wife will see it and
it'd be a whole shitstorm meddling
bitch,
but if they can just load up at the
local seven,
11 on $50 worth of Bitcoin,
have it transferred to their account and
then they do that.
Can you buy Bitcoin at 7:11?
Basically you can use a,
like various money services are you used
to be able to.
But uh,
that's where things are headed.
I think that we're getting.
Are Their ATM machines now coming
online?
There was one in Boston that I saw a
video of.
Yeah,
I've seen that as well.
That's interesting.
If they,
that would definitely open the door.
And for folks who don't know technology,
I'm porn opens up the door to technology
all the time.
I mean when online video,
online statistics,
all that stuff came from adult stuff.
Well,
when apple cut flash out,
when apple stopped flash on the IPADS
and on their laptops and they um,
when,
when they're on their phones rather when
they did that.
The what is the other five htp?
No,
that's the,
that's a supplement.
Html five html,
http get new boots.
They put new mood and their computers.
But when they started using html five,
I mean all the,
the porn sites started adopting it.
I mean it was like almost instantaneous.
We used to not be able to watch porn on
your iphone and then pop pow.
There it is.
There's just like,
these are human forces.
People need to watch porn.
People need to translate it.
David Seaman,
do they need it?
People need to transact.
Yeah,
they do need it.
Fuck yeah.
Look,
look at the Middle East.
I think half the issue with the Middle
East is that guys are just not getting
off enough.
You should put like a thousand rubbing
tugs in the Middle East and just see
what happens.
There's definitely that.
And there's,
don't quote me on that,
but I wouldn't.
A postal address like Jabba the hut,
you know,
that's an issue to you.
You're covering them up.
No,
it's just so repressive and I understand
like you got to respect someone's
culture,
but you also have to respect the fact
that a lot of these people living in
these societies probably don't want to
live that way.
That culture is a trap.
There's a problem with any suppressive.
Culture is a trap and you can't get out
of that trap.
Especially if that trap is tied to
religion.
If you're eliminating inflammation,
you're eliminating progress,
you're eliminating people growing and
you're doing another name of religion.
You know what,
man?
I really,
if I don't know what God wrote or what
he didn't rope,
but I highly doubt if he's the way
you're describing them,
this awesome,
amazing guy.
I highly doubt he gives a fuck what kind
of clothes you wear.
That's just me though.
I mean,
I'm not thinking for God or anything,
but I just highly doubt.
So what you're dealing with,
most likely,
I'm not saying definitely,
but most likely it's some bullshit
written by people and it's poisoned.
Your culture absolutely poisoned the
very foundations of your culture and
won't allow any progress.
It will not allow new information.
It will not allow consideration of old
ways.
The way
you live is perfect and it will not
change.
You're going to be cotton camels heads
off the fucking dull knives to the end
of time,
and that's just what it is.
What what you're doing is how you're
always gonna do it.
You're always going to say,
I'll walk by.
You're always going to fucking dressed
that way.
You're always going to bow to the east.
All that same shit that you've been
doing since the beginning of the
millennia.
You're going to continue to do that.
That's nonsense.
Well,
if you're labeling somebody you disagree
with is an infidel or as not an infidel,
not a lot of room for reasonable
discussion there.
You're like,
here's my point,
and then the other person's point is
you're an infidel.
If we had a softball team,
we would call ourselves the infidels.
That'd be dope.
A good name for a strip club.
Yeah.
I have a gre podcast,
softball team,
costs of the Jerry infidel.
It wouldn't be a good neighbor.
Strip club.
Make all the girls.
We'll veils belly dance
bad.
They wouldn't feel bad about seeing
their face.
She couldn't see him and be like,
they're robbing a bank when they're
showing you their pussy.
Yeah,
right.
That's a good idea.
Actually called the infidels and all
girls wear veils.
It's not a bad move because a lot of
women,
you know,
I'm thinking it would want to have
anonymity.
We think so.
I think so.
I saw a,
a as soon as actress at a coffee shop
near my place the other day and she was
sitting at a table by herself and had on
like the big bug eyes,
sunglasses,
like she's like a praying mantis pretty
much.
And uh,
I just think people can't want that,
you know,
like maybe you want it five percent of
the time.
But I think in that particular moment
somebody would not want that.
Oh,
you mean that amount of attention?
Yeah.
Because if you're a woman in some of
these Arab societies,
you can't just walk around like American
style.
Uh,
I think it was on one of your podcasts
actually some guy was jerking off on a
rooftop because he saw like a woman's
Vale come down or something like they're
very sexually repressed.
So you can't even just dress normally in
a coffee shop without getting the same
kind of attention that over here and a
list actress would get.
Yeah,
that's true.
Um,
well,
just the idea that you're supposed to
cover your head,
right?
Always.
Always wear a veil like,
and it's unsanitary.
You think over time.
No,
not really.
I mean,
didn't know more than wearing a baseball
hat.
Right?
That's on sanitary.
I just don't have your hair.
Everybody.
Everything.
Okay.
Under there,
it actually protects your hair.
There you go.
Fun in damaged,
damage your hair.
So it can,
we'll definitely damages your face.
Well,
all this bullshit that people worry
about like the uh,
cell phone,
neuro tower weapons or whatever.
And wait a minute,
hold on.
A people hanging out with people.
Tweet me some weird shit.
It's like the guys at radio shack can
you got to stop fighting with people on
twitter,
man,
you really do.
When people say stupid shit to just
ignore it and block them,
please.
Yeah,
I've got to do that.
You get locked into it and then you're
like,
I'm retiring from twitter.
I get locked into.
Like recently I was,
it was Sunday morning at 7:00
AM and my phone goes off and I'm like,
Oh,
what is this?
And it's all caps,
like hatred from some psycho and I'm
just like,
take number one,
you know,
connect your fucking phone to your
twitter.
I got to turn it off.
Of course you no still has
it that way.
Doug Benson,
ladies and gentlemen,
you want to fuck with Doug Benson right
now?
Tweet the shit out of him.
Just fucking tweet them.
Constantly.
Tweet them all day because it's fallen.
We'll just.
It'll run out of batteries in 10
minutes.
I'm like,
how long has your battery lasts?
Like 10 seconds.
I mean,
I assumed it was because my iphone is
shitty batteries,
but allowing the world to text you
essentially you're allowing the whole
world filled with assholes to text you.
Right?
I got to turn that off.
You know what?
This is going to help me more than going
a infrared saunas and all the bullshit I
do to relax.
I'm just going to take twitter off my
phone.
Yeah,
that.
Well,
you're dealing with too many people.
You know when you.
When you deal with that many people,
you can't have them at their discretion.
Get in touch with you,
right?
You have a certain amount of
responsibility to try to connect with
people online because it's what you do
and it's what I do as well,
but you can't allow them to just do it
at their discretionary time because it's
intrusive.
Your,
your regular life is important.
Like you have to be able to have time to
reflect.
If you don't,
you'll never form your own opinions.
You're just be constantly inundated with
information and other people's activity.
You can't do that.
You can't allow that.
It's.
It's a symptom of.
It's a symptom of the new world and you
know you are experiencing it in extreme
form because you're sort of a public
figure and you're a journalist and
you're controversial.
Utah,
you cover a lot of very fascinating
subjects,
so you're going to get a lot more than
the average person who has this set up
like that.
It's just too much,
man.
You can't do it that way.
That's very true.
Do that.
Starting today,
my phone would explode if I did that.
It would literally shake.
It would just shake and just boom.
Sparks would fly out of it on your
phone,
like froze up because of something
happened.
All these people text you and you're.
I was just thinking that I was thinking
like the twitter app probably can't
handle that many things at once.
Just frees up a one time I accidentally
gave him my cell phone number out on
twitter.
I was trying to send it to somebody in a
pm and I sent it.
I sent it to the whole world and my
fucking phone literally just shut off
and rebooted.
It was like,
this has got to be right.
I'm going to reboot myself.
I've rebooted itself.
Just was like,
fuck you,
and committed suicide.
So awesome.
It was just my.
My inbox filled up in five seconds and
then the texts that were coming,
there's just.
I tweeted something yesterday,
somebody sent me that.
I was talking about how I felt when my
child was born that it was.
Oh,
I was thinking about how crazy it must
be.
How many different babies being born
right now?
If you could see them all in real time
in front of you,
like on a giant screen.
It'd be like a baby invasion.
I mean you don't think about it because
in that hospital room,
while that one's being born,
well,
somebody sent me a tweet and that tweet
is a link that shows in real time every
baby being born all around the world and
it is a fucking invasion.
It's scary APP.
Yeah,
it is like if Obama gave out his cell
phone,
it's like heaven.
It's just one baby baby,
baby,
Switzerland,
Africa,
Indonesia,
China,
and I know and that's just the reported
babies.
That's not the little tikes shit out in
the bottom of a fucking grass hut in the
middle of the jungle.
They didn't count those.
They only counted the ones.
The ones that are in the census.
Yeah,
I mean,
do you see Brian find the link?
Was it yesterday?
Yeah,
it was A.
I quoted it as a.
As a retweet.
Instead of a retweet.
I quoted it.
Oh,
here we go.
It's crazy.
It's so nuts.
You go to it and it's.
What is the website for folks who want
to get to it?
Yeah.
Google.
Dr.
Com.
No.
What does it say?
A bunch of Google drive.com.
Sounds legit.
We'll look at that.
Those are the babies.
See those babies on both sides.
Holy Shit.
That is scary.
Isn't that incredible?
Yeah.
Those are all babies.
It's going to be deaths going about.
I don't see a lot of us second.
Not a lot of us births.
How is that only google?
Dr.
Com.
That's all it is.
Why?
It's good.
Good.
Dr.
Com,
black sides host.
Oh,
a bunch of other shit.
So the stuff that we can't see,
that's all like real blurry.
That's the other stuff.
Do you think this is what the NSA sees?
They see like every new human being
coming online?
Yeah.
The NSA is,
they're paying attention 24 hours a day
to every one of these babies.
Make sure they're not fucking doing
anything illegal.
So get all these babies is crazy.
There's a fucking.
And I feel like we're going to run out
of oxygen or something.
It's terrifying man.
And I don't see a lot of American flags
either.
Man.
I see a lot of those other countries,
a lot of the red Chinese flag that
bothers me as an American.
I think we need to do our job and do
some more fucking.
Most of the deaths.
China is number one.
Most birth India.
Look at that.
It just stopped.
What if freaked out?
No.
But your computer crash?
Well what if they just stopped having
babies?
What is one day?
We went on that thing and it was a day
where there was no babies.
That movie with,
uh,
with Clive Owen.
Children of men?
Yeah.
When people stopped being fertile or
something stupid,
you know,
well that is the,
um,
the people that are not dooming gloomers
about overpopulation,
their idea is that as time goes on,
what's going to happen is the cultures,
like third world cultures that are like
really into having a massive amounts of
child children,
childbirths,
those are going to become more developed
and as they become more developed,
we're actually gonna have a decrease in
population.
That's the non doom and gloomers.
They obviously don't have this website
on bookmark.
If they did,
they would see the fucking invasion in
real time see it happening.
Oh my God,
how,
how we're going to have enough oil.
Well,
there's a theory that the more people
you have in an area,
the more kind of like intelligent
productivity you have.
So higher population doesn't lead to the
Malthusian meltdown where people starve
and kill each other to get back into a
lower population realm.
Instead.
It's the high population itself.
That's what is leading
to innovation.
And somewhere along that innovation can
keep up with the higher population.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
So it's basically you look at humans
like kind of like a network capacity.
It makes sense.
What,
what concerns me most?
Those are just the actual natural
physical resources.
Oh yeah.
I watched him.
Pollution and pollution.
I watched that movie.
Jiro dreams of Sushi.
That's a great.
I've talked about that movie like 30
times.
I'm obsessed with it.
Really interesting.
Weird.
You know.
First of all I learned two things.
One,
I would never want to be a fucking Sushi
chef because they work too hard.
Those fucking people work hard,
man.
The apprentices who are,
they stay apprentice.
So they're like 50 years old.
Yeah.
How about the fact that the guy worked
on making eggs for like 10 years before
he got it right.
And then when the guy told him he did it
right,
you start crying.
What?
You cooked an egg,
right.
That's why that movie is so beautiful,
you know,
because we will be sick of that shit
after 15 minutes.
This guy has a 10 seat room.
It's a 10 seat room in the Tokyo subway
station that's booked out for months are
booked out from us and it's the best
Sushi in the world apparently.
And the guy,
I mean his,
his son's 50 years old and his son goes
to the fish market every day and buys
from the same guy who's like literally
got a flashlight on the tuna and
touching it with his fingers and he has
to make sure it's,
he has a feel for the texture,
the texture will directly contribute or
directly correlate with great flavor.
Like he knows what textures the right
one.
Then they know like how to age the tuna
and you know how long for an old tuna,
how long for a young tuna.
Fucking crazy shit man is a true art
artisans.
When you imagine if we had that in the
US,
like at every level of our society,
somebody putting out a new APP,
like the new facebook APP is like,
I'm not sure if this is perfected yet
and they just study it for the next six
months before they release it.
Yeah.
No shit man.
And I mean there's no money to be made
and what this guy is doing either,
I mean there's enough money to keep
afloat,
I'm sure,
but he's got a 10 seat fucking place and
these people talk about his Sushi,
like you know,
restaurant tours and restaurant critics.
And they say they get nervous when they
go there.
They get nervous when they meet him.
The guy takes the same fucking subway
everyday,
sits in the same seat,
Exxon at the same stop.
He's 85 fucking years old and he's been
working every day since he was like
fucking 20.
Look at what an old boss as though if he
comes back up there.
Yes.
Yeah,
no,
that's his son.
His son's 50 like everything about the
way they cook.
The place is fucking amazing and made me
want to fly to Japan.
Maybe want a book.
I bet you can't even book online,
but you've got to go there in person and
get your reservations.
But it made me want to try this Sushi
and finding what the fuck is all about.
He probably gives you like a riddle,
like a Zen Koan that you have to solve
and if you solve it,
he's like,
okay,
three months from now launch,
we're on,
and if I was going to do what I would
want to do it quick before that whole
place is nuclear war Godzilla shows up.
It was,
this shit
is pretty,
uh,
unsettling.
Very unsettling.
But you know,
there was a sign
just that went there and was catching
fish from right off the shore and they
tested 50 tests a flounder I think.
What's the other word for a flounder?
Good grounds.
Old men have been the sole ground fish
flatfish one of those flat fish.
But the point is those,
those fisher,
the,
they stay in that area,
they're not migratory.
And it was,
you could eat.
It was fun.
Yeah,
it was fine to eat.
So what he's saying is that the ocean is
so fucking enormous that it's not really
having the same effect that people think
it has.
Yeah,
it is scary stuff.
The water leak is very scary.
It's still dangerous.
Dissipates out enough that the ocean.
Yeah,
the ocean is so goddamn big that right
now it's okay,
but the real issue is not just
Fukushima,
it's these nuclear plants in general.
I try to make it relative.
Someone like I had a conversation with a
friend who is a very pro business and
very pro,
you know,
nuclear power and the benefits of
nuclear power and he's talking about
these few places where the issues have
arisen and I said,
well,
okay,
I just want you to think about the
amount of time that nuclear power's been
here.
Okay.
Now think about the amount of nuclear
power plants that exist now.
Think about how many of the men have had
catastrophic failures only to write only
to.
You're right,
but those two,
those places are fa hucked forever.
There's two and it's less than 100 years
of nuclear power.
How long do you think people bit around
what if people around another 20,000
years stop and think about how many of
those nuclear power plants are gonna
fuck,
fuck everything around them.
There's two places right now,
Chernobyl and this place,
and then there's a three mile island or
four mile island or whatever the fuck it
is.
That place is kind of fucked,
but not quite as fucked.
I don't think we know enough about it.
I think that we're too.
It's too new for us and we don't have
the the timetable that you would need to
do it properly.
Sure.
You're absolutely like our lifespans are
just too short.
We're like fucking fruit flies working
with this technology that has
ramifications.
That will be around for thousands of
years.
Why don't our lifespan is nothing
compared to the lifespan of any kind of
leak will.
Also we.
We grew up in a time where these things
that already existed and we didn't have
any say in their construction and so
they were manufactured by people kind of
assumed there may have been around all
that.
Technology's probably oldest fuck by
now.
It is old as fuck.
The one in Fukushima is old as fuck.
It's outdated technology,
but they kind of assumed upon
construction that with innovation,
with progress in the future,
there's going to be able to be a way to
correct all these issues.
Well,
there's not.
There's still isn't.
At least with coal power plants,
even though those are messy too,
it's only fucking up the present.
It's not like you're leaving this thing
that for thousands of years is going to
be a,
you know,
making children have birth defects and
stuff.
It's like,
you know,
it's messy when it's drawn out of the
earth.
It's probably not good for the at all,
but it's temporary.
It's not something that's destroying
areas for long time.
Yeah,
it's interesting.
It's like you,
you look at what people are willing to
accept and not willing to accept just in
the name of,
you know,
having fuel just to the name of progress
just in the name of financial reward and
it's,
it's kind of scary how flippant people
are about polluting the ocean,
about polluting the BP oil spill.
You had Peter Schiff on and we were
talking about the BP thing and you know,
he was talking about.
Yeah,
I listened to that one.
He,
he kind of gets under my skin because a
lot of the limited government stuff I
can latch onto and agree with,
but then there's something,
I don't know how to describe it.
It's like there's not a certain humanism
there that you need to have.
Yes,
like everything doesn't have to be in
your framework of the free market
principle.
That's great for a lot of Shit.
If you want to get the best water or the
best soda or the best weed,
it's probably a good idea to get free
markets working there.
So you have competition.
It doesn't have to be for every single
facet of life.
Well the real issue with him is
environmental.
That's the real issue.
His willingness to,
you know,
the fracking thing like his,
his concerned about fracking was so it
was,
it was,
it was really funny.
Like talking to them about people that
have had their land is destroyed forever
and he was saying,
well they got millions of dollars.
Most people,
they got money that would've never been
able to get.
They got hush money,
but it's still,
their land is fucked like that.
The money is all.
It's all relative.
Like what's a million dollars to Peter
Schiff?
It's probably not nearly as much as it
is to those people.
So for,
for Peter Schiff,
a million dollars or whatever the fuck
these people,
that's worth it to destroy a piece of
property essentially for as long as
people wasn't around.
What was weird about that too is I think
you asked him about the environmental
impact and he said there's nothing wrong
with fracking.
There's no environment.
The environmental impact,
and we know that's not true.
Like just google it.
It's all over the place.
It's not true at all.
There's over a thousand documented wells
that have been polluted from fracking.
Yeah.
You know,
the idea is that if fracturing works
exactly according to plan,
it's so deep in the ground that you're
not going to disturb wells,
but it doesn't work according to plan.
It's a crazy business.
What'd you do?
You're pumping water into the center of
the earth.
You're creating earthquakes.
You know,
and I've had a lot of people google me,
like you need to get up to date with
your research,
like really right wingey type people who
are pro business,
who by the way almost always financially
struggling but,
or clearing the way for the one day when
in the future they have money,
they're going to go out,
you know,
they're gonna,
they're gonna need the regulations to be
kind of light because they want to make
some money in this,
this economy.
Well,
all these people,
like I would send them to all these
websites and then they would just vanish
like you can't say anything,
so I'll just send you,
I'll send you all the links.
I'll send you the fucking one of the
ceos of exon petitioning to not have
fracking on his property.
One of the richest.
No,
fracking is short for hydraulic
fracturing.
It doesn't sound like something that's
good for the earth.
Yeah.
Exxon CEO
is hilarious.
So he doesn't want it near his property.
Yeah.
He doesn't want fracking.
He thinks it's going to fuck with his
property values of.
Yeah,
it does,
Dude.
Yeah.
Exxon CEO doesn't want fracking facility
near his US home.
He files a lawsuit.
You fucking dirty,
man.
You're a dirty man.
Rex Tillerson,
he is that his name?
Rex tillerson sounds like a dinosaur.
It sounds like an industrialist for like
the 18 hundreds.
So scary.
You ever seen there will be blood.
Yes.
Yeah.
It sounds like one of those guys.
Exactly.
Yeah.
This is a.
Oh,
this is not an anti fracking lawsuit and
experts said nothing.
Could be further from the truth.
Yes.
A lot of things could be further from
the truth.
It could be that a quarter is actually a
Gremlin.
Who Lives on the moon and likes to suck.
Baby.
Dick's.
Okay.
That's further from the truth.
You fucking dummy.
Nothing could be further from the truth.
Oh,
the earth is really a Frisbee.
Is that further from the truth?
You fucking cunt.
You shitbag lawyer said they will not be
a sponsor of your podcast anytime soon.
They can all fuck themselves.
Citizens of Bartonville described as a
wealthy community,
which you'd expect that giving the
houses of the chief of Enron have sued
to stop the tower.
The tower is being built by cross
timbers water supply.
It would be a 15 story building adjacent
to Tillerson's 83 acre horse ranch,
not far from an 18 acre homestead among
the others who opposed the project or
people not exactly known for their
environmental concerns form a US House.
Majority leader,
tick amny and his wife,
for example,
all these fucking rich country they're
putting in their neighborhood and they
don't want it.
Oh,
you guys are fine.
When it was in Baltimore,
all right.
You guys were fine when it was in the
middle of Pennsylvania shitting into a
river that people like to fish in.
Fuck all you.
Fuck all you fucking criminals.
You shitty environmental criminals.
You guys are ruining the earth.
This is not a way to do it.
You can't just pump water and chemicals
into the ground because we know that
there's gas and oil there.
That's county shit.
This is a terrible idea.
Well then we extract the water
afterwards,
Brian dunning sales.
No worries.
Afterwards,
we simply extract the water you ever
heard his video on.
It even takes on it and affected accent
like an what hosts.
There's some no worries,
like peaceful accept.
Talk like a fool,
like,
oh,
don't worry.
Why?
Hydraulic fracturing.
That's literally what he sounds like
when he talks about it,
explaining how simple it is.
Oh,
it's only poisoned to thousand wells so
far.
It's only been around for a few decades.
Don't worry.
What's a thousand places that are
poisoned forever.
No worry.
I think we're predisposed to listen to
people who sound reasonable.
Yeah,
reasonable and what happened saying
David,
seaman,
let's be reasonable.
Hydraulic fracturing is very safe and
should ask for it in your community
today,
forward in your own home.
Hydraulically fracture your own gas from
the ground below you.
That's like the reverse mortgage guy
that's on at nights and convincing old
people who a cash in their home equity,
you know,
like it's a good way to.
It shows him in front of a sports car
and it's like,
yeah,
you get a sports car but you also lose
the fucking equity to your house.
I'm like,
dude,
no longer own the house you live in,
but at least that is just financial
money comes and goes and is there.
You're not poisoning the fucking very
water that people can drink.
You're not changing the water like
people used to be able to use that to
fertilize crops,
to feed their animals,
to drink.
Now they drink it.
They get like neuro toxins.
They get like anybody's in nerves.
Stop working.
Anybody who thinks that's totally okay.
I would recommend the prescription of
Yoga,
meditation,
weed,
Brownies,
as long as permissible by law.
All those things would all three of
those things would be the Trifecta of
not being a dick anymore.
The weed brownies or the most
introspective in like if you want to
think about a drug that makes you
consider everything that you're doing
wrong,
God damn those things get to the heart
of it helps me see like the other
person's perspective and then even if I
want to go ahead with what I'm doing,
at least I've seen it from their point
of view,
so it's not coming from a place of
ignorance coming from,
Oh,
I see both sides,
now I can do what I want.
Whereas before,
you're just the person who doesn't see
how the world is perceiving it and it's
kind of scary.
It's scary to me that I went that long
without,
uh,
using that stuff.
Well,
it's the,
the reason for a lot of the people that
have these negative opinions on
marijuana brownies or cookies is that
most of the times that they're used
recreationally,
most of the Times people are using them
just sort of have fun with or they're
fucked up.
They're already drunk and then they
associate being hung over and like
making bad decisions with the marijuana
has nothing to do with that.
What people think of it as more of a
party thing,
which you kind of can be mean and it is
fun to get high and watch star wars with
your buddies.
It is,
it's fun.
You know,
if you have a bunch of people over the
house and he'd go,
let's eat pot brownies and watch star
wars.
Fuck yeah.
You know,
it's fun.
It's also fun to watch star trek by
yourself like every day on that.
But it also.
But besides being fun,
it most certainly can be a tool for
psychological expert exploration.
You really can,
you can explore some areas of your
consciousness that maybe you didn't know
were really troubling you,
and then all of a sudden they get
dragged into the forefront and some
spotlights get turned on them and you
didn't even know that you had some sort
of a subliminal or subconscious hiding
of these ideas.
Yeah.
I'm not a scientist at all,
but I really believe that stuff like
that has evolved alongside us.
And that's part of the reason why it's
not harmful.
Why nobody ever ods on marijuana is that
we've had time to adapt to it and it's
adapted to us and we have this symbiotic
relationship where it's making us a more
introspective
and we're able to innovate as a result.
And because of that,
we tend to grow more marijuana,
which keeps it alive and keeps it
thriving.
So it's like this,
uh,
this thing like a coral reef almost.
And then we come along with modern
society.
We make all this shit illegal just for
the sake of it.
And we do away with things that people
have had is basic tools for most of
human history.
You think about it like this shit is
only been illegal for what?
Like 70 years?
Yeah.
The main thing you're dead on.
I think that's exactly what's going on
and I think it's changing.
I don't think you can stop the change
that's currently underway.
I think what Colorado did and what
Seattle or Washington state did that
those decisions were made by people
they.
And then you see that not only is the
sky's not falling,
but those people are making a lot of
money and then then it just opens up and
now that the banks are going to be
allowed to take the money from the
Colorado dispensary's,
what do they call them?
It's legal.
It's not a dispenser.
If it's legal,
is it a pot store
dispensary?
If caregiver shit,
maybe not your share giver because it's
not medical,
it's just the store.
Then Rato was just selling weed.
They just gave up on the whole medical
thing and they're like,
yeah,
we're just selling weed.
Come on in Seattle still hanging back.
They're like,
oh,
well what are you guys doing?
I think they'll see that people are not
going to go crazy and it's going to help
the local economy a lot and then other
states who want to adopt some form of
that.
Yeah.
Colorado is like the crazy friend that
eats the mushrooms first car.
I was like,
you guys share that.
That's not a much of a kill you.
I'll fucking eat it,
man.
Colorado's like your crazy friend who's
like real skinny but never gets sick and
he's got a cowboy hat on and he's like,
I'll eat that fucking Brownie Brown.
So Colorado just goes,
hey man,
we'll just fucking start selling it and
we'll see what's up.
And so all these people have started
these huge businesses and within the
first day,
within the first seven hours they'd made
millions of dollars.
I mean the,
the amount of money that's being there,
this tourism,
like people are driving from Wyoming to
go to Colorado.
So they combined the cuts.
It cuts down on crime.
I have a friend who actually is a
manager at one of the dispensary is out
there in Denver and she was telling me
when one of their dispensary's moves
into a neighborhood,
all the people stopped going to their
dealer and they just come into the store
and that's their new place obviously,
because they want to do something that's
less risky.
Yeah,
you've just fucked all those dealers out
of their money like that's done.
Now it's being taxed now.
It's being regulated.
It's helping people because people are
being paid jobs that actually pay well
instead of just one drug dealer taking
all the money and it's interesting for
their own.
They can grow their own as well.
Well,
you know,
that's another beautiful thing about it.
You don't have to worry about the cops
coming to your house and breaking in
your front door because you got a plant
somewhere in your closet.
You don't have to worry about that
anymore.
It's okay.
It's legal.
I really liked the balance that La is
struck where there are dispensaries you
can buy from and you see the green,
whatever it is.
Yeah.
The plus sign,
but it's not in your face,
so if you're somebody who doesn't like
or it makes you paranoid when you do it
or you just have a conservative
upbringing,
it's not something where you're
constantly confronted by it.
I think that's cool.
It's like if you want it,
it's very easy to get.
If you don't.
It doesn't have to be a part of your
life.
That's the way it should
like it in their neighborhood.
I think.
I thought it was really kind of
hilarious.
I was driving down the street with a
friend of mine and it was in his
neighborhood and there's like the green
plus signs and he's like,
you know,
these fucking things are all over my
neighborhood and I'm like soon as the
liquor store.
Stupid is the liquor store right there
by the way,
you smoke pot.
What are you talking about?
And no,
nobody.
Nobody leaves the dispensary looking
unhappy.
Like people always leave liquor stores
looking all bummed out.
People leave dispensary's looking the
same way they leave when they nutting
their pants,
when they go and get a lap dance like,
oh boy,
I can't believe I got away with that.
They get in their car and they drive
away like some kind of a criminal.
I think,
um,
you know,
people just have this attitude that,
having a dispensary somehow or another
different than having a liquor store.
This guy's got a liquor store,
right?
Me Drive out of his house,
take a left,
go down the hill,
Bam.
There's liquor store is a fucking
dispensary a mile away from that is like
in my neighborhood.
So what's all this green plus sign
nonsense.
Or when you're out with somebody and
they smell it on a sidewalk and they're
like,
they're kind of offended by it.
I'm like,
why are you offended?
This is fucking cool.
It's peaceful.
It's if people are having a good time
around you,
it doesn't mean that there's crime or
danger.
Not only that smells good.
Yeah.
You got caught a plus sign instead of a
green cross.
You're just like,
no religion on across.
Yeah.
It's supposed to be like Red Cross
screen,
cross.
No,
no,
I think that's probably true.
Green Cross.
Yeah.
But I mean even the cross is not a cross
anymore.
It's a plus sign.
It's not religious,
but it's not.
It's good to have crosses an extended
bottom.
There's a difference in the shape.
Essentially.
It's like the Red Cross's cross
medicinal use.
That's why it's a cross.
That's why it's a green cross.
Yeah.
But you can't really call it a cross.
I like plus better anyways because it
doesn't have any kind of religious
connotation.
Yeah,
I mean it.
Was that really what Red Cross is
supposed to be though.
Is that why?
Why is it okay?
I don't know.
Okay.
Let's Google it.
What?
That's one of the great things about
being a journalist is a,
when you get to the point,
you just realize you can say no to
things and that's the best way to do it
because you have google.
You don't have to like draw on what
little,
you know,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
No worries.
Um,
what.
So the green plus sign on pot
dispensaries.
Okay.
Um Hm.
It doesn't say,
how has this not been asked a thousand
times over in like reading reddit trees.
It's an interesting thing because like a
lot of these stores,
that green plus sign,
it's become so universal that's,
that's all it has on the sign to have a
green plus sign and then I'll say like,
w,
you know,
the whatever,
West Valley caregivers was one of them.
So it was Wv,
CGI,
that's all it said.
And then you get near the West valley
caregivers like,
what the fuck are you actually selling?
And they get in there and just tanks.
Uh,
we'd be like,
oh,
I see what you're doing.
Unfortunately that place that I used to
go to,
my favorite spot,
the government told them that they had
to close down because they had opened up
a too late,
like after a certain amount of time they
weren't approved or something like that.
And the dude was like,
he was very nervous about it because
they had shut,
gotten shut down once for something
else.
And the guy who owned it previously
wound up going to jail.
He was,
he was one of the few people that got
popped.
Actually he didn't know him that when he
owned another one,
but I know one of the guys who got
popped and wind up doing time and then
there's some guys in San Francisco,
those guys,
a pot university guys,
whatever the fuck they are.
Cannabis University,
those guys are still duking it out in
court.
Pot,
pot,
McCormick,
todd McCormick,
todd mccormick.
Our friend is involved in some legal
bullshit.
Again,
it's crazy.
I only do delivery nowadays.
I don't even go to this store is a smart
move man.
Yeah,
I mean look,
there's,
there's plenty of weed and it's way
easier to get and it's way more relaxed
but it's still sketchy federally and if
someone comes in after Obama,
which is very likely,
that is a more repressive because this,
this Obama thing has been a goddamn
mess.
I mean he,
what he's done and what we thought he
was going to do are so polar opposite
and you know,
they didn't stop the Dea from rating
these medical marijuana facilities.
There's a lot of raids during his time
if you want to go and look at how many
raids took place during Obama's time.
It's been quite substantial.
The blowback from that has also been
substantial and it's very damaging to
his party because he's essentially a
Republican in wolf clothing.
What I mean,
a lot of the shit that I've done outside
of social things have been like really,
really similar to what the Bush
administration did.
There's been a lot of really negative
shit that's happened with the dea
breaking into these pots doors,
putting fucking boots on kids' necks and
taken like there was one that they did
where they got caught doing all this
because all the film was sent remotely
to another location,
like constantly.
It was currently sent so no one can
steal the hard drives.
The security cameras.
We're still recording,
so the so seed got to see them put their
boots on this kids neck,
throw him to the ground.
Just a kid.
Just a young 20 year old kid working in
a place that's just pull all the money.
Just people being thugs.
They steal the money.
Well,
if they know that these people aren't
threats,
you your break,
you see 20 year old college kid is
working there and national security
threat investigation,
you know who these people are,
you know who you're arresting and you've
got your boot on his neck.
One of the people who are trying to
relax,
people are trying to find like more,
uh,
healthy outlets for their anxiety or
their uncertainty.
So the point is there's probably going
to be someone could easily bribe a
politician to go hard on these things
with the new administration office.
If there was a big push by the
pharmaceutical industry,
it was a big push by the alcohol
industry,
big push by whatever prison guards
union,
whoever it needs to be.
The can grease the wheels
to get them to be harder on marijuana.
It could conceivably happen that the
genie's not totally out of the bottle
yet,
but I think that the chances of that
happening are thankfully not that high
because the cat's out of the bag.
The public knows that marijuana is not a
bad thing.
Now it's a good thing.
And that's a very,
that's a very hard thing to.
How can you outdo that at this point?
Doesn't matter how many reefer madness
as you put out,
people have come to the conclusion that
it's actually not bad for you.
Did you see?
And what about her?
She was on Piers Morgan talking about
pot.
I'm sure she's against it and put it on
and coulter on Piers Morgan talking
about pot,
not just against it.
She's so ridiculous.
It's so hilarious because first of all
it's working,
right?
We're talking about her.
So obviously her trolling people like
that just want to stay in the media and
they don't realize the real harm they're
doing to the,
the national discourse.
I agree with she,
she got,
she got you to mention her name just now
and now she's going to get booked on
another show because of this.
So will be on the today show and that's
great.
So she can sell more books,
but she's fucking over people who
actually rely on what they see on tv and
she's just fucking up the whole
discourse.
You got it,
Brian?
Five seconds.
Yeah.
She's,
um,
she's a terrible person.
I mean,
what she's doing is for her own benefit
and that the trolling when you have,
why is it illegal?
Cannabis,
cigarettes,
alcohol,
I answer.
You're going to interrupt me and say,
no,
it's not true.
That.
Explain why.
Well,
I kept trying to.
When you had been dropping.
Now I'm going to explain now.
So don't interrupt.
Um,
look,
the sole purpose for smoking pot or
eating a pot Brownie is to get high.
That is not true with alcohol.
Okay.
Pause it right there.
She's wrong,
right?
They're like,
what is crazy?
What does that mean?
Who gets he gets he drinks not to get
drunk.
Yeah.
I drink whiskey for the taste.
Imagined he fucking sitting around
drinking whiskey.
Like imagine if they came up with
alcohol free whiskey and they sold it in
those big arnold palmer lemonade cans
with alcohol free whiskey.
They're trying to do that with weed.
They're trying to give you the uh,
the benefits without the high,
like extract that and put it in a pill.
I think that would fuck people over.
No,
no,
no.
They're actually the scientific research
behind that is for extract cbd.
It's for pain is for micro under chronic
pain that they don't want to get high,
but okay,
that's different.
My thinking was that they're kind of
like,
oh,
you can use the medical benefits as long
as you don't get high from it.
And I think that this is totally just my
own perspective.
I really think that part of the
medicinal properties of marijuana is
that it allows you to see things
differently and I think there's much
more of a connection between the mental
and the physical than we're willing to
accept in our Western society.
And I feel like most humans up until
about 100 years ago took most of what
I'm saying for granted.
Like you remember reading books like
novels of the 18 hundreds where
somebody's sick and their doctor says,
go live somewhere,
like go live in the countryside.
You'll feel better.
And they would prescribe this shit
actually works because if you're less
stressed
out and you're in a better environment
and you get better,
your body knows what to do.
And,
uh,
we've totally,
like,
we try to be so clinical with everything
that we can't let somebody just get high
and fucked up for a few hours and figure
out their own shit.
It has to be very clinical,
you know,
you can't actually feel something that's
altered state of consciousness,
although I agree with you on that.
I think the scientific principle or the
scientific reasoning behind extracting
CBDS,
it just so that people who have injuries
can have pain medication that's natural
and have it while they're at work.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Don't get hooked up or.
Hi,
I'm thinking of something else then I
gotta use the bathroom.
So.
No,
I don't think there's anything wrong
with what you're saying because I think
you're right in a lot of ways as well.
But I think that the,
um,
there's a bunch of reasons why they
extract cbd from cannabis and they're
not all,
it's not all,
you know,
the,
the man wants to keep you down.
So play this fucking wacky bitch player
some more
or a 14 year old going to everybody.
Everybody drinks alcohol to get slightly
higher than when they start drinking it.
Julie Pierce Morgan.
Absolutely.
I am done TV after drinks.
I bet you you have to you right now that
will explain a lot of things.
Have you.
Would you please let me finish one?
Tendons,
Piers Morgan will take your rainbow.
Enjoy wine.
They drink wine for a purpose.
Over $800.
Bottles of wine.
Perhaps you have a warm feeling.
It does not.
You can tell if somebody's been smoking
pot.
They're eyes are red.
They giggle at everything and by the
way,
they're incapable of carrying on the
normal.
Have you ever smoked pot?
No,
I haven't.
Never know.
Hold on.
Pause.
How ridiculous that they're incapable of
carrying on the normal functions of
life.
I do Jujitsu.
I'm high.
I do comedy while I'm high.
I do in this podcast.
Hi.
I do almost every radio show ever do
high that the normal functions of life,
like what?
We go to the movies high all the time.
Go to dinner.
Hot all the time.
Like what is she?
What is she basing it off as?
Does she have one ex boyfriend that's a
pothead that she's basing opiodes about?
Stop and think about that because she's
dating.
If that is the case,
she's dating a guy who's willing to
tolerate her,
so just imagine what kind of a fucking
idiot he's going to be an o.
He couldn't.
He couldn't function well.
Jesus Christ,
he pro.
It was probably paralytic.
Just being around your fucking shitbag
personality.
I'm imagine that.
Imagine that woman,
that's your girlfriend.
Oh,
he couldn't.
Couldn't function in life.
So is that.
Or if it's her friends,
like she says,
she knows a lot of potheads.
She has potheads have friends,
you know what she's doing.
Is that by just trolling like that?
See,
that might've been okay.
That controlling that she did when she
started doing it because when she
started doing it,
she was trying to get an alert coming up
some,
some lawyers on that thing.
When she started trolling like that,
it was probably pre-internet,
you know,
I mean she was probably doing that shit
way before.
The only way for her to get attention
and the platform,
but now that she has a platform,
she should use it for good instead of
glee.
We'll stop this information.
Sub being a silly bitch like you know,
have a nuanced point of view.
Can you do that?
Well,
what can it not just be a right wing
fucking chatterbox.
So like people like that who claimed to
be limited government and conservative
[inaudible].
Exactly.
It seems to me like they pretty much
just want lower taxes because if you
really believed in limited government,
how the fuck can the government tell you
that you can't put something that's
first of all safe in your own body and
the comfort and safety of your own
fucking home when you're an American
citizen and supposedly live in a free
society,
you should be able to do that in some
way.
Do I think it should be taxed and
regulated?
Absolutely.
Keep it safe.
Keep it on the books,
but why shouldn't you be allowed to do
that?
I'm sure she doesn't have a real
argument against that,
so it's only ad Hominem.
It's well,
they're lazy and you're like,
well,
what about the Beatles?
Were they lazy?
What about Steve Jobs?
Is he lazy?
You know,
like you're just isolating one anecdotal
fucking thing.
Exactly.
And that's not.
I can make an argument against alcohol
based on some guy outside.
He was drunk in front of a liquor store.
That doesn't mean you shouldn't go out
drinking with your friends.
Not only that,
look what she's using as an example
she's talking about while you were in
the bathroom,
she was talking about,
uh,
you know,
you could drink it and have a warm
feeling like,
come on.
You're.
So what you're saying is you can't smoke
just a little bit of pot and just relax
a little.
You can have a very mild pot candy.
There's a,
a pot candy that speed weed has.
It's God damn perfect.
His God damn perfect.
You can have one and it's just a mild
edge.
Really reduce search.
Smile.
So mild,
like really like to play pool.
I like to take to heart candy one.
Yeah.
But one one is great.
It's like you don't feel perplexed.
You don't get that.
Like what were we talking about?
You don't get any of that.
It's a dosage issue.
It's the same thing with everything.
The idea that alcohol is more,
you know,
you could easily under dosed with
alcohol and just have a warm feeling,
but you can't do that with marijuana.
That's so foolish.
It's so dumb and it's so ignorant to
human physiology.
It's so ignorant to all the different
things that we use on a daily basis
where if you overuse them,
they would fucking kill you.
I mean,
there's a huge amount of medications
that people take on a daily basis where
if they took 20 times more than they
were supposed to take their dead,
you know,
salt,
10 ounces of salt,
you're a dead person.
She's in sleeping pills.
Fuck yeah.
Tylenol,
pms,
and tylenol is apparently really bad for
you.
If you drank,
you should not take tylenol.
I didn't know this until a couple of
years ago.
If you drink,
you should not take tylenol as your
hangover cure.
You should take some advil.
Acetaminophen is really tough on your
liver.
Oh yeah.
That stuff's not good for you.
I know a guy who takes,
he takes,
this is a crazy cocktail,
but he takes adderall.
He takes Xanax and he takes ambien.
What does have been prescribed?
What is that about exactly?
What is that about?
Like,
I'm going to speed myself up so I can
slow myself down so I can relax.
Speeds himself up.
Then apparently you get a little freaked
out from that.
So he needs something to relax and
that's where the xanax comes in.
But then he can't go to bed at night.
So he needs the ambien.
I totally POW,
POW.
I totally do that with coffee and
alcohol though,
because what happens is you have like a
meeting at 6:00
PM so you get all caffeinated and then
it's 6:45
and you're in your apartment.
You're like,
fuck,
I need to chill out.
So you start,
you start drinking because you're so
amped from the caffeine.
Well,
I used to have a buddy that had a crack
habit and uh,
I used to go with them,
uh,
and uh,
go to the liquor store when he was
fucked up and he wanted to calm down,
he would go to the liquor store and he
would buy a 40 ounce just to like bring
his heart rate down.
Wow.
And he would,
uh,
yeah,
a healthy living right there.
Oh,
he's dead.
sorry about that.
Yeah,
he died.
He was,
this is why I'm not a comedian by the
way.
No,
you can't.
I couldn't get upset at you for seeing
the healthy living.
It's obviously not healthier.
He had a lot of,
a lot of drug problems,
but he wound up dying because of it.
And um,
but just seeing him trying to calm down
by drinking,
pounding this 40 ounce of beer,
just try to get the alcohol into his
bloodstream to just alleviate the,
the crazy heartbeat that he had going
on.
That's where the dea and stuff like that
is fucking up also,
is if they've betrayed the trust of
young people by lying to them about
marijuana.
So as a result,
there are probably people out there who
are like,
well,
maybe not that bad.
Exactly.
Maybe crack cocaine is not that bad
because they completely lied to a some
marijuana and I remember as a kid in
middle school they had a cop come to our
classroom and give us the whole day or
breakdown and he had a suitcase filled
with like fake versions of drugs and
what they look like.
And I was thinking like,
even as a kid I was like,
how ridiculous is this?
Now I'm an expert on all these drugs.
Look like before I didn't know shit
about half these things down,
like practically a drug dealer based on
this fucking infomercial.
Like here's all the stuff that you
should never look for,
don't look for this one.
It comes in this kind of bag,
you know?
And I'm like,
what is this?
Some kind of weird propaganda.
There's education and knowing what not
to take as long as you're honest about
it,
as long as you go.
Now this one is actually just the dried
plant.
It grows all over the contiguous United
States.
It's been used for thousands of years,
by the way.
You just said contiguous.
I've never used that word ever.
Have you ever used contiguous?
Yeah,
of course.
No,
it's a good word.
Thank you.
So I,
uh,
I read a lot of Shit on my kindle and
then certain words just get into my mind
is a good one and I'm like,
I'm going to use this next time.
I feel like using it rocket contiguous.
Hope you use it correctly anyway.
So it's already being fact checked.
You're right.
You're absolutely right.
It's that if they said that,
if they're honest about the look,
you shouldn't do this one because it's
going to lower your motivation.
At least stay away from it until you get
into college or until you get a job or
whatever it is that you need to get.
You should avoid if you want to be as
motivated as possible.
If they said that,
then I'm like,
okay,
then I'll listen to you when it comes to
stay away from the crack cocaine because
it will fuck up your life,
which it will,
but you don't trust that person.
I have no trust what they say.
Well,
it also fucks up the relationship that
people have to law enforcement.
It fucks up the relationship that people
have to people in positions of authority
that you legitimately need to protect
you in a civilized society and that's
what the cops should
be.
Being a cop should be an honorable
position that's very difficult to
acquire.
It should be something that we really
respect and we love and appreciate the
people that are around us that are there
to help us.
If some shit goes wrong,
if some bad people around,
if some people are victimizing other
people,
some people are breaking the law.
That should be a part of our society,
but when they become a dea person and
they're shooting someone's fucking dog,
cause they got a plant growing in the
house.
I mean how many of those God damn videos
you have to see for you realize there's
a problem with the fact these cops think
they could just break into someone's
house and shoot the fucking dog for
nothing.
They shoot shoot dogs that are behind
dog gates barking,
little tiny dark.
He just shoot them.
They shoot them because they want to
intimidate the fuck out of the people.
They want to let them know,
look,
I just shut your fucking dog.
You're going to start crying and I'm
going to get what I want,
and it's part of the power trip.
It's part of the thing and it's part of
what makes people distrust cops and
that's fucked.
If cops didn't have to deal with these
laws,
if there wasn't laws that were unjust on
the books,
then this sort of behavior would never
take place.
If you couldn't do that to someone,
you couldn't break down someone's door
and and fucking shoot their dog.
If you could only go and arrest people
who are committing crimes,
our whole attitude crimes have
victimized people.
Our whole attitude about law enforcement
would change.
It would make it better for them.
You know?
They will become like firefighters.
It would become an integral part of our
society that's absolutely necessary
except for the people that are fucking
committing the crime,
which we don't want in the first place,
but it has to be real crime.
It has to be crime and creates victims,
victimless crimes or horse shit crimes
against yourself,
their bullshit.
You can't stop a person from cutting off
their own fucking finger.
Did you know that?
If you decided to go get a bolt cutter
from fucking Home Depot,
take it home and hack off one of your
fingers.
No one can fucking stop you.
You go to the hospital and they say,
what happened?
I cut my finger off of the bolt cutter.
They're not going to arrest you.
They're gonna go,
why'd you do that?
You're like,
I fucking hate that finger there.
Go,
all right,
well,
don't do that again.
You idiot.
You're going to die.
You know you've got an infection.
Take these antibiotics and get out of
the hospital,
but how come you can cut off your
fucking finger?
But if you see a guy who likes to smoke
pot,
you can arrest him.
You could arrest him for what?
What's he doing?
He's doing something to his body that
you don't agree.
Is that what it is?
Because there's no victims.
Here we're is.
You're a victim.
Is the smoke going into the air and
polluting our modern discourse?
Is it.
Is it fucking taking paint off cars down
the block?
No,
it's not doing a goddamn thing.
There's no staff.
There's no crime.
There's no crime and dance where we have
to make a distinction and the reason
why,
one of the reasons why that distinction
is very difficult to make is because
there's people that have made these laws
and enforcing these laws.
A business.
There's a business not just in keeping
prison guards in in work,
but keeping prisons filled and keeping,
making sure that prisons generate income
from bringing prisoners so they make
sure that laws are in place that
absolutely ensure that they're going to
have new people in there every year
because people are going to keep
breaking these laws because the laws
that are ridiculous,
the laws that have been in place since
the beginning of the time and those
laws,
they they,
they,
they're about 30 percent of the people
that are in prison.
That's what's so fucked up about it.
Do you think that these laws,
these anti psychedelic and anti
marijuana laws are actually like a form
of societies immune system?
Kind of going overboard?
Like I think about how some of the most
brilliant people seem to have some kind
of interaction with drugs at some point
in their lives,
whether it be steve jobs with the acid
trips or you know,
pretty much any musician with weed or
any writer with weed at median,
with.
Okay.
Any comedian,
it unlocks a lot of potential that
otherwise wouldn't be there for people
and it shows you the world in a
different way.
Especially if you do something that's
even stronger like a psychedelic.
It's showing you something.
It's almost like root access to a
computer where it gives you a lot more
power.
But for most people you don't want root
access.
You just want them to have their,
you know,
their web browser and that's it and you
don't want them fucking stuff up.
I wonder if society as a whole is to
kind of unconscious thing that goes on
is like,
this is really powerful stuff,
so we'll allow some people to have
access to it,
but we can't just let the whole society
go.
Timothy Leary,
you know,
tune in,
tune out,
whatever his thing was.
Because what will have as a result is
completely uncharted waters that we
haven't been to before and there are
people really afraid of that happening.
Well,
I think if you have to look where these
laws coming from,
are the laws coming from really educated
philosophers and scholars?
Not so much the exempt.
No,
no.
These laws are coming from people who
are doing a lot of fearmongering.
You remember all the shit that Ronald
Reagan was saying back in the day.
Well,
it turns out that marijuana may be one
of the most damaging drugs known to me.
The most dangerous job.
You know,
it's,
it's that kind of shit.
Those are the people,
these people like this and coulter Twat.
Let's finish listening to this because
it's so fucking ridiculous.
Play it more.
How do you know what it was?
My best friend,
no,
she's not.
I doubt that a lot of friends,
um,
maybe bill Maher is going to still get
their pod.
They're probably self medicating,
but the more people will take it and if
it is made legal vastly more people will
take it.
Disaster for commerce.
Commerce.
That's hilarious.
Contents are incapable of following
simple instructions and getting the job
done.
Piers Morgan's body language.
He's like this fucking person that I
have to interview a drag on the economy.
He's awful too.
I was just fine.
Great.
What do you mean by pop?
Was um,
when I'm,
I'm moved to a new place in California
and there was a cool pool guy.
I didn't,
you know,
I'd come back and it's four feet down
and it's called covered with green mold
and I called him up.
He was a pothead.
Oh,
I was there.
You know how silly that is?
I want to talk about anecdotal evidence.
She met a pool guy who was a pothead who
didn't clean our pool.
So therefore what a selfish con People
Centered Company,
$800 bottle of wine just talking about
$800 bottles of wine and then she talks
about how her pool couldn't do
his job because he was high on pot.
Let me try.
Let me try and stop the stream of
consciousness.
Yeah.
Anything done with a pothead.
What we need to do.
Everyone knows what a pod had.
It doesn't mean it's not smoking pot one
time.
How much are you assuming a pothead
takes enough so that it can be made fun
of on TV promoting a narrative.
It's heavy drinker,
heavy smoker,
no heavy smokers work all night and then
die young,
saving the social security system money
and we for a commerce commercial
purposes,
for the purposes of the good of the
country,
we ought to encourage Americans to smoke
like mad.
They'd be incredibly productive.
Well,
you're seeing laser John.
He's encouraging lung cancer.
You're seeing right now is a human who's
screaming for a psychedelic
intervention.
If we could get ann coulter into a
jungle retreat in Peru and force feed
Iowasca with one of those things that
they use for fog wall when they stuffed
goose filled with grain to make their
liver fat and delicious.
If we could do that with her with
Iowasca,
just pinched her nose and our mouth.
Pinot.
Just pin it together.
Hold onto it,
force it down.
Walmart.
Hold it in there and make sure your body
absorbs it.
No,
throw up and then let this bitch go on a
wild ride on the feathered snake and
come back.
She doesn't eat dick too.
She needs Dick too,
for sure.
Sure.
Well,
you know what she needs.
She needs Dick.
That actually wants to fuck her.
She probably can get some Dick,
but it's probably a mess.
They're both drunk and you know,
he was breast mouse,
some weird Fox News producer just on top
of her wedding.
Stinky feet was fucking slippery.
Socks on.
The whole thing is a mess.
I'm sure.
It's disgusting.
She's gross.
She's a gross human being and not just
gross like with,
you know,
she,
she's not an ugly woman.
She's not my favorite,
but her personality is gross.
It's.
It's just so insensitive and aggressive
and ego maniacal like what what she's
saying is so preposterous and so
obviously so.
Obviously trolling.
That's what she's doing.
Fucking done.
She's the master troll the day.
See the new Godzilla trailer out today a
little bit more.
This case was more things to yell and
then we'll play that because that's so
much more awesome.
It's not heavy drinkers.
When the cat is out of the bed,
you can put it back in.
That was the problem,
but here's the problem,
but the issue is again,
to pick up where I was in the middle of
my sentence,
but during prohibition,
that isn't a big deal.
Why do we treat it?
Alcohol related disease,
cirrhosis of the liver,
accidents as a result of alcohol.
One down precipitously.
It will go up.
We will have luck.
This is how many fans we have.
One that's just about enough that nobody
has ever overdosed on cannabis.
Did you know that they can perform daily
functions.
They're going to be on my tax bill.
You the people.
Can you accept that?
People can overdose on too much.
Everybody dies.
Eventually
you just contradicted yourself.
Eat dummy and do you encourage cigarette
smoking on television.
What
she's doing right there is just being a
silly person,
which she's doing right.
There is a purposely trolling,
which he's doing right there is just
trying to get attention and holding onto
an argument that doesn't have any basis
in logical thinking.
Her argument is just about her trying to
get her point over.
She's just a shitty example of a person
who's allowed to talk.
So that's what it is.
You know you shouldn't be.
You shouldn't be given that sort of a
platform if that's the kind of thing
that you do because it's so obvious.
She's not a thinker.
What she's doing is she has an ideology
and she pushes that ideology at the
expense of all the contradictory
evidence.
You know,
no matter what she's.
I mean,
she's talking about fucking alcohol
being okay.
Cigarettes being okay,
marijuana being back,
they're going to be on my tax bill is
her concern.
Well guess what,
Hooker,
I'm not on your tax bill.
There you go.
I smoked pot.
It's a dumb thing to say,
it's just the fucking Nancy grace thing.
They're all lazy.
Particular look at you fat.
So are you.
Are you a fucking maniac?
Mountain climber is that you running 100
miles every morning.
You're fucking lazy.
You're lazy bitch.
You're lazy.
Fat Face Bitch.
Okay?
Patil,
lazy dummies out there talking shit
about pot.
It's not pot and you know Ken pot make
you lazy.
Well,
it can relax you and if there's.
If you have a tendency to want to not do
things,
pot will definitely accept you.
Accentuate that tendency,
but being lazy is a state of mind.
It's what you decide,
the direction you decide to pursue your
life.
I'm,
I am not lazy because of marijuana.
I am more introspective and oftentimes I
get more done because of marijuana
because I have more interests.
It's just we have these perceptions and
we have these stereotypes that have been
reinforced and movies and we have these
ideas and we have these ideas that are
coming from a person who clearly doesn't
smoke pot.
Clearly she's not eating pot cookies and
exploring your conscience.
I don't believe in any kind of media
laws,
but I almost feel like there should be a
law where if you're going to talk about
a subject this big,
you actually have to have firsthand
experience,
so if you're talking about marijuana is
harmful,
you must have actually used it yourself
more than once before.
You can talk about it in that manner.
If you're talking about Bitcoin,
you actually have to have used it at
least once.
If you're talking about anything.
If you're talking about being
unemployed,
you have to have been unemployed at some
point or at least interview somebody
who's unemployed now and not just
pontificate,
which is what so many people do.
I agree to a certain extent.
I think the marijuana thing is it's also
troubling the format in which they're
communicating in these goddamn formats,
these television formats or so and I.
I didn't realize it when I was younger,
but now after four years of podcasting,
I'm so aware of what the difference is
and communicating like that and
communicating like this.
Like when you.
When you do Jujitsu,
like say if you're a really good at
Jujitsu and you roll with someone who's
just really strong,
he wrote with a guy who was like a good
athlete.
It takes you a while to get them,
but you're going to get them so it's
going to take a while.
Like if someone doesn't know Jujitsu but
they're really strong,
you might not be able to hold onto them.
They might throw you off them,
but eventually they're going to get
tired of doing that because they're
doing it the wrong way and you're going
to get them.
When Ann cultures on a Pierce Morgan
show,
she could say a bunch of crazy shit
because she knows the commercials come
in at seven minutes.
She can start this ridiculous argument
that's completely securitas.
It doesn't have an ending to it,
and he.
There's,
there's going to be an interruption,
will be right back,
and then they're going to cut to
commercial and they're going to come
back and she's going to babble some more
so she can sprint.
It's just like a fight.
We sprint in between rounds,
sprint,
and then in between rounds you relaxed
and then you come back with some other
fucking inane argument and the next
round and that's what she's doing,
but if you got her on a podcast for
three hours,
I would brian downing her.
I would do exactly what I did with that
guy.
You just talked to them and allow them
to express themselves until you reveal
how ridiculous they are.
Yeah.
If she.
If she were,
if she were here,
she wouldn't be able to do a
intellectual hit and run where you throw
out like this huge character attack
against weed smokers and then it's over.
Exactly.
I would let her talk,
let her talk.
I have hours to kill.
Let's go.
Come on,
get to it,
and after awhile you're going to get
tired.
You're going to get tired.
You get tired of saying nuts.
It's going to get tired of sprinting
with nonsense and then slowly but surely
we will compile facts and slowly but
surely we will present you with examples
of people who use it,
who are healthy and who have benefited
from it.
And I'll tell you my own personal story,
I benefit from it,
and then we can compare and you can tell
me if you'll you think that Eddie Bravo
is lazy.
You think that one of the best Jujitsu
instructors in the country,
one of the first American ever Tappa
Gracie.
You think he's lazy?
Lazy.
Oh,
you think he's lazy.
You don't just stop and think about all
the comedians we know that smoke weed
that fucking constantly travel across
the country that constantly writing and
performing are they lazy and now you're
you're lazy thinking and in saying that
you're lazy and if that's the type of
discourse that you pursue,
if that's what you're trying to do,
that's what you're trying.
That's a lazy way of being a human
being.
That's the lazy way of operating and
incredibly complex neural system.
That's a lazy way of being a functioning
human being who has given this
incredible position of communicating
with the world because you have
responsibilities when you're
communicating with the world and one of
those responsibilities is to express
yourself to the best of your abilities,
to look at life through the.
What are you doing?
I'm sorry,
express yourself to the best of your
abilities to look at life through the
most nuanced and objective perspective
because you're.
You're going to say some things are
going to influence a lot of fucking
people.
How much have you looked at it when her
case?
Obviously not so fucking much.
Her Pool Guy,
she taught us the pool.
The pool was green.
Oh,
you fucking poor,
baby.
You poor baby.
Was Your Pool Green?
How do you go on?
How would you go on?
There's a lot of beautiful people that
smoke marijuana,
beautiful spiritually beautiful.
Personality wise,
there's a lot of lazy people that smoke
marijuana.
There's a lot of lazy people who don't
smoke marijuana.
There's a lot of lazy people who drink
coffee.
It's a tool like any other tool,
it can be used or it can be abused.
You know?
It's like my old joke from one of my
bits.
You can build a house with marijuana.
You know,
you could,
you could smoke pot and use it to design
things,
but it's just like a hammer.
You could,
you know,
you could build a deck with a,
with a hammer,
you could hit nails with a hammer or you
can hit yourself with a dick if you're
fucking crazy.
It doesn't mean that hammer should be
illegal,
right?
You could design furniture on marijuana.
You could build a fucking airplane on
marijuana.
There's a lot of things you could do
while you're on marijuana.
He can write a novel on marijuana,
which has been done many times.
Even king wrote,
almost all his shit was just a lot of
coke to.
It's probably a bad example,
Stephen King on writing,
whether it's a mixed example.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Look,
people should be able to do whatever
they want to do as long as you're not
hurting others.
If you're taking marijuana and you wind
up becoming a fucking rapist.
If Marilyn,
if there was,
okay,
let's not say marijuana with.
There's a cactus flower that people
found in New Mexico and for some reason
that makes you a rapist.
Like everybody takes,
it becomes like a rape Zombie.
Yeah.
They should probably make that fucking
thing illegal.
Yeah.
You know,
you started eating people's faces in
Miami.
That shy legal.
Yeah.
Well you know what's funny about that?
That was what they started saying was
marijuana.
The guy was the Zombie that they said
they tested him and he tested positive
for marijuana.
That was the only drug he didn't test
positive for.
Bath salts.
It's with all the stories,
but this is how piss poor the media is.
And when you're giving out these five to
seven minute blurbs on information,
well why didn't test positive for bath
salts?
Because there's no test for bath salts.
You fuckhead they don't have a test.
That's interesting.
So they're just making this shit up.
But what does bath salts,
what about salts with it?
There could be a variety of different
compounds.
Storage,
just a media term for this.
Exactly what man drug will with these
man drugs are,
is you take an illegal drug,
you alter it so that it's no longer
illegal,
but it's still as ridiculous effects on
the human body and then you sell it as
not for human consumption.
It's not just one simple formula.
They don't just take math and add
phosphorus to it.
I mean there's a bunch of different
versions of these bath salts,
so if you're saying that you didn't test
positive for back salts,
you're right and you're wrong.
You're right.
He didn't test positive,
but the reason is they don't have a test
for it.
So of course he didn't test positive for
bath salts.
You said a test to a lab.
They're going to test for a bunch of
different shit.
They're going to look for,
you know,
cocaine.
They're going to look for alcohol.
They have.
They have a spectrum that they look for
things in.
They're not.
Unless you specifically tell them what
kind of bath salts,
they're not going to look for that.
It's not going to be what you know.
It's not going to come up with a check
mark next to bath salts.
So they tried to blame it on marijuana.
Say this guy smoked pot and eight guys
face like,
I doesn't happen sometimes.
Sometimes I'm like,
I want in and out,
and then I went somebodies face.
What they don't realize is how
attractive they made.
We'd after that because people go,
I want the fucking Zombie.
We'd I want that.
We'd that made the duty to dude's face
Zombie Kush.
That guy might not be to be able to
handle it because he's crazy homeless.
Fuck,
but if you give that Zombie face eating
wheat to a regular dude,
he had mad munchies.
Yeah.
He couldn't.
Couldn't even take it anymore because
get get this dummy off here and I say
dummy.
With all due respect,
no need,
no need to have ron anymore.
It's.
I just,
I feel bad for her.
I honestly do because I feel bad for the
viewers.
I think that's going out to people's
homes.
These toxins are being pumped into your
living room.
She's a middle aged woman.
You know what I mean?
She's not going to get any better.
It's not gonna.
Get any smarter,
which,
which is what she is.
I feel bad if you,
you know,
you've lived your life and accumulated
information and had life experiences and
this is the result.
This is who you are.
That's a disaster.
That's a attention seeking missile to a
disaster that's destroying lives along
the way with it's fucking shitty
personality.
It's just so unfortunate.
It's unfortunate for her.
It's unfortunate for the people that
listen and don't realize how ridiculous
or opinions really are.
When you look at the actual facts
themselves,
it's the anti anti marijuana rhetoric.
It's just.
It's so stupid.
The.
Yeah,
there's.
There's definitely problems with people
using marijuana,
but there's problems with people use
toothpaste.
There's problems with people using glue.
They take glue,
they sniff it and they go,
fucking crazy.
People are nuts,
man.
There's 7 billion of us on this planet
and there's a certain percentage of us
that can't handle anything.
Why?
Because they were raised poor because
the race in a poor manner,
shitty I should say,
because their genetics are poor because
they're.
They have birth defects because there's
environmental hazards because they have
disease is because fill in the life
experiences,
fill in a traumatic childhood.
Incidences fill it in,
fill it in for why they're fucked up,
but a human being is a very complex
puzzle that doesn't always come together
correctly.
It just doesn't.
There's a lot of factors that have to
do,
you know,
that have to fall into place to make a
David Seaman to make a guy can come on a
podcast and be articulate and express
information and have all this stuff in
his head.
You have to have a lot of factors in
place,
not it doesn't always work out that way.
It's one of the beautiful things about
running across a guy like you or a cross
and anyone who's got their shit together
because it's not easy or you and your
podcast just attracting a million
listeners and building up something.
You didn't do this with a network
backing.
It was just your own thing and it grew
over time.
We also did cool.
Didn't do it,
trying to do it.
That's part of the,
you know,
we,
when we had these discussions,
there was nobody listening so we just
expressed are our thoughts and it allows
you a platform to explore,
but these,
these like five minute blurbs where
people run on and start arguments on
television just to try to get people to
buy their book.
It's the silent movies,
man.
That's some old shit that doesn't work
anymore.
The world is complicated and a five
minute conversation on a very complex
issue that has a massive social impact.
Massive,
both positive and negative,
like everything,
like every fucking good thing in this
life.
Driving has a positive and negative
effect.
I am not going to stop driving.
I like being able to get somewhere
quicker than walking,
but driving kills people.
There's car accidents,
you're breathing in brake dust.
If you live in a fucking city,
forget about the pollution from the
engines.
There's no free lunch.
Everything has a plus and a minus,
but it's our job as human beings to to
have a balanced approach and here's
what's not good.
Suppressing and making something illegal
that's beneficial to millions of people
and if there's any lesson to be learned
from prohibition,
it's the rise of organized crime because
when you turn regular people into
criminals,
the criminals are going to provide those
regular people with drugs and it's going
to be on taxed.
Unregulated
definitely.
And then they just corrupt the officials
and the whole thing becomes its own
little environment and it gets
entrenched and that's what you have is
now you have powerful cartels that want
to keep it illegal so they continue to
so they can continue to make money off
of it.
Yeah.
And I don't really hate and culture.
I have nothing against that woman.
I feel bad for her.
I feel bad that she's that person now.
I really do.
I feel bad for anybody that's in that
position because that's such an easy for
a person who has experienced life
through as much of an objective lens as
you can and you see a person like that
that's a.
that's not a person who's at their best.
That's not a person who has done a lot
of soul searching,
a lot of thinking and it's come to this
really peaceful,
loving conclusion.
That's a silly person.
That's silly.
Person has to be themselves and live
with their own
Mary's every night.
That's not fun.
Yeah,
she's not that.
She's not having a fun life when you're
talking about how he lived in a fucked
up world and people do crazy stuff and
you know,
things are mixed.
Uh,
I wrote this article the other day that
a lot of my readers didn't like,
but I think it's one of the better
things I've ever written and it's where
I take this angle where I'm like,
what if President Obama is right about
most of this stuff?
You know,
like he's doing a lot of stuff that is
arguably not constitutional.
However,
there are 7 billion people on the
planet.
A lot of them are driven by hateful
ideology and certain parts of the world.
And in a nuclear age,
it only takes one of them.
It doesn't even take a nuke.
It takes another nine slash 11.
Like,
I mean,
I guess going from Ann Coulter did nine
slash 11 is natural.
But,
uh,
I can start to see the other side of the
whole argument.
And I think you have to be able to do
that if you're doing the kind of work
that I do is I have to see where people,
like General Keith Alexander are coming
from,
which is the argument that we can't,
sorry that we're looking for your text
messages that sucks Boohoo,
but we're not going to allow another
nine slash 11 to happen because we don't
want to have 3000 innocent people die
and have the economy crashed and have
total chaos for the next five years.
And so I can see things in that light.
And I wrote this article coming from
that place of,
you know,
he's kept us safe and I realized that's
a total Bush era argument and it's the
kind of thing that I normally despise.
But you have to be willing to explore
that and explore the fact that it's the
year 2014 now,
uh,
he's been in office since January 2009.
And you have these fear mongers and the
alternative media who,
people who I don't want to disc because
I do their shows and they do mine.
But uh,
you know,
people like Alex Jones,
basically it's fucking 2014.
Like if what you're saying is true,
why are you not in a gulag somewhere?
Why aren't you in a fucking dungeon
tower being tortured by homeland
security
for one thing,
he's easily dismissed because he's so
crazy.
I mean,
you could pull up a million videos of
him screaming and ranting and raving and
you just dismiss him right away.
But my,
my point though is like Obama is not the
boogeyman that he's been made out to be.
I think that what he is,
is somebody who's trying to do the best
they can within an extremely fucked up
and flawed and piece together system
that is dealing with like 15 different
entities at once.
You know,
like whenever the dea breaks in
somebody's door,
that's not because Obama.
Obama's like sitting in the White House
on his ipad and he's like,
Oh yeah,
let's go to this guy's house.
Right?
Like he's got other things on his mind
and yet we link all this to Obama and we
should instead be trying to modernize
the whole fucking system so that Obama
has less to do.
Well,
I think there's a very good point in
that and I agree with you on looking at
the other perspective.
I think that's very important and people
are very reluctant to do that.
People are very.
It's one of the hardest things to do was
hard for me to write this article
because I'm like,
fuck,
I'm like defending everything that I
don't believe,
but you're not.
You're exploring that idea and I think
you should be allowed to explore an
idea.
I think it's important to be able to
explore an idea and people on the left
are people that are,
you know,
anti war or in rightly so.
They would like reject that
instantaneously.
But I think that to get to know what you
really have to explore it.
I think to,
to,
to look at the,
the holes in the argument,
even to look at it from a defensive
point of view,
you have to explore it and look at it
from their point of view to understand
them.
I think that I would agree with you in a
lot of ways that Obama,
Obama,
who's,
that Obama has one of the most thankless
jobs ever and it's unbelievably fucked
up situation to try to deal with however
he's lied about things and I have issue
with that.
I have issue with the lying about the
NSA collecting metadata like that.
I mean,
how long did you think that that was
going to stay a lie?
I mean that,
that was gonna sit out there before
people found out.
I mean,
people exposed to that was not true
within days.
And
there's a new one that's out today.
I wrote down,
don't go negative,
but,
uh,
there's a new NSA snowden document that
the NSA and the GCHQ,
which is the British version of it.
Uh,
I guess the British government's NSA,
pretty much.
Uh,
they have this whole a procedural thing
for how to go after activists that they
don't like and harass them using troll
identities,
like literally their slideshows,
showing how NSA agents troll people they
don't like online and destroy their
credibility and reputation and this is
shit that even a week ago to say this
would be like kind of out there because
like,
sure,
like maybe governments troll people,
but you can't say with authority,
like the US government and the British
government or trolling people they don't
like now we know that this is a fact and
that's something that needs to be reined
in because that's not,
you're not paying for that because we're
paying for this crazy district.
We're paying for some antisocial
sociopath's to get a paycheck every two
weeks from the federal government to
fucking do crazy stuff on the internet.
It's so funny,
man.
It's so funny.
It's just hilarious that they've.
I mean,
think about what is the,
that job.
I want that job by the way.
I want the lowest form of life on online
troll.
Yeah.
And that's what,
that's what the government does role.
I mean,
it's hilarious and it only works if you
pay a attention,
but you know,
if there's enough people working for the
government,
they're trying to discredit you,
I'm sure they could put a good dent in
public perception of you,
but I think that's,
I would say that's not what you're
supposed to be doing if you're a fucking
government.
Alright,
you're supposed to be in a government is
one of the things.
It's sort of a lot of ways like what you
shouldn't do when you argue with trolls
online,
like you shouldn't do that because you
know,
you just got to accept the fact that
you're in an unusual position.
Well,
the government's in an unusual position
to Obama with that.
He was basically getting trolled by
Snowden for a little while.
Like I was watching this and I was like,
it's absolutely ridiculous for a US
president to be lowering himself to the
level of a 29 year old freelance
contractor for some defense company.
How is he.
In what way was he going to.
By addressing the issue and making it
seem like,
you know,
snowden's the problem with it should've
been is immediately the second this shit
came out.
If I were one of Obama's advisors,
I would suggest just be honest with you,
will be like,
it looks like some stuff went overboard.
There were some things that should not
have been occurring.
I'll put an end to it,
will appoint a panel to look into it.
It's not what America is about and we
went overboard because we didn't want to
see another nine slash 11 happened and
so of course some programs crop up over
time to keep you safe and some of the
shit is unconstitutional.
We'll fix it.
And most people,
I'd say like 99 point nine,
nine percent of people including myself,
would have been like,
you know what?
Job Well done.
You know,
we don't need to fixate on this fucking
thing,
but Jones instead,
it was like a manhunt.
It's like the plane was forced to the
ground somewhere and to search for
snowden and it's been in the news for
months.
Like,
what is this?
It's ridiculous.
Yeah.
Well,
it's also,
what did he do that's so terrible.
He released information about crimes.
Yeah.
I mean if you look at what is law,
what is law in this country?
Well,
there are laws and there are precedents
that have been set way back to when the
founding fathers had no idea were ever
going to have a fucking internet.
They had certain laws that were in place
in order to make sure that people's
rights are protected and that the
government doesn't get out.
I got a hand that law enforcement
doesn't get out of hand because people
who have ultimate power,
it corrupts them.
It's just.
It always has.
It's had since the beginning of time,
whether it's a fucking security guard at
a mall or whether it's the president of
United States power is a corrupting
thing and these laws in place,
they circumvented those laws.
They changed those laws.
They pass things like the NDA.
They pass things like the Patriot Act.
They pass all these things to make laws
that are in place to protect people's
rights.
Invalid.
Make the fourth amendment invalid and so
then they feel justified by doing what
is essentially a crime.
Well guy comes out and says,
Hey,
a crime is being committed on 300
million people
in this country and multiple millions
worldwide by a group of Americans who
didn't get a license to do this by any
voting,
by any court of public opinion.
These are unelected officials.
This is scholars,
this is Bob Smith,
and suburban Virginia is looking,
looking through your emails potentially
if they just have the power to do so,
so because they have the power to do so.
The acted on it and that's crime.
That is a crime.
We have laws.
So what snowden did was calling him a
trader is one of the most disgusting
labels you could ever label.
A guy who took his own life and
sacrificed to safety and security in
order to enlighten the millions of
people that are crime is going on.
I mean,
he's a modern Paul revere times a
million.
I agree.
And he had a nice life in Hawaii.
He had the dancer girlfriend and he's
making good money for a 29 year old.
Now he's under the fucking the
crosshairs.
He's in the cross hairs now.
He didn't have to do that.
He made a choice and he's definitely not
an attention seeker.
Don't think Putin's not hooking them up
though.
You think you're talking about with some
Russian slowly Mowgli,
Russian chicks,
Russians.
Chicks are probably way harder than
that.
Check.
He was banging in Hawaii.
He's probably got some evil Russian
liver steel and chicks,
the kind.
You fuck them and you'd get all groggy
and you wake up in a hostel.
Yeah,
we're in a tub filled with ice.
I don't know.
I mean,
I,
I don't know what's really going on with
him,
but uh,
if I had to guess,
I think they take care of him.
I think he's probably.
Okay.
Well think about it.
If,
if there were like a,
if it were a Russian snowden and he came
to the US,
we would totally hook him up.
We'd make them go into NASA.
The US government would be singing his
praises every day.
It's kind of creepy when you realize
that that does happen.
They do steal like scientists and they
steal like,
oh,
we're all competing with each other.
Like the US is one of the major super
powers and we're in this dystopian novel
right now where everybody is spying on
everybody else.
We have satellites and uh,
I think the US is the least evil of the
superpowers by far and the most
promising one,
but we should still hold ourselves to
the highest standard,
but shouldn't it be like vicious about
it?
I think there's just a lot of
incompetence.
I think that's a lot of what leads to
these evil decisions and behaviors,
so things to think about how this stuff
is doing their job and all this stuff is
getting out these lame powerpoint
slides.
It feels like something from the office,
you know,
like the bullet points are like go after
the activists damage their credibility,
bring it up a search for.
I'm on dirt,
that's the website.
It's dirt.
Some tech blog and one of their top
articles right now is about the NSA
thing.
They have the actual slides.
Oh No,
you got to see some of these because
it's so like,
it's just the combination of evil and
mundane.
This,
that is just weird,
you know,
because it's people making these things
and people making these policies and
it's just incredibly vicious stuff.
That's so hilarious.
It really is hilarious.
It's,
it's hilarious how incompetent they are
and in a lot of ways it's almost like
it's on purpose.
It's like the whole thing is being
done on purpose.
Maybe they're not incompetent.
I was thinking about this too,
how the government puts across this
image like,
oh,
we're just a bunch of bumbling morons.
We shut down the government because we
couldn't agree to something.
We don't know what's going on.
And meanwhile you have the NSA has these
protocols for harassing people were very
smart at some level,
like we know there.
Those are the slides.
It's so funny.
Leak confidential information to
companies,
the press via blogs,
etc.
Post negative information on appropriate
forums,
appropriate forums,
stopped deals,
ruin business relationships.
Isn't that set uP a honey trap?
We'll get that set up.
A honey trap.
What are you going to do?
It sounds like the stuff they did to
assign a damaged credibility hook him up
with a girl.
Oh yeah.
Well,
what exactly did happen with the
sausage?
I mean,
what for folks who don't realize he's
not in,
if you don't know juliana songs is,
he's in the west,
which embassy?
Some south american and some south
american embassy I should know,
but I forget.
I should know too.
Um,
but he's not there because of what he
did by leaking all that information.
In fact,
that's not really a crime that you could
get a guy on.
I mean it's,
it's just,
it's,
it's not the same kind of crime.
The reason why they've got him held
hostage is because they say that he had
secret or surprise sex with a woman,
which means he had sex with her while
they were wearing a comment.
Condoms.
She agreed to it.
And then while they're in bed
afterwards,
I guess they were both naked and he
stuck it in without a condom.
He pulled the creeper switcheroo and
that's surprised sex.
I guess that's.
It doesn't even sound like a real thing.
Like how is that?
What does that sound like?
A real gentle attention.
I mean like how does that require being
on the books?
Surprise.
So I don't know man.
It's,
it's confusing as fuck that.
That could actually be something that
they could hold a guy in an embassy for.
How many years now have been there for
longer than a year?
Long time.
It's got to be kind of like trying to be
in the same place.
Oh,
it's got to be brutal.
It's probably,
it probably drive you fucking crazy.
It probably will.
I probably really will drive you fucking
crazy.
That poor bastard.
Okay.
Stuck.
He's stuck there and he probably will
die there.
They'll probably make sure he dies
there.
A vitamin that can be crazy if he's
there like 20 years from now,
30 years from now.
I think some president will probably
like part time or something.
You think so it would hopefully way,
way,
way in the future for that to president
snowden and like 20,
45 months.
Miley president miley cyrus president.
mildly in two years or no,
she's got to be what?
Like 45 years old or something?
Yeah.
Got to be in your thirties,
36,
isn't it?
To be president,
something like that.
Somewhere I'm just hurts.
It just hurts.
It just hurts that.
It's that transparent.
It hurts that were that bad that after
all these years of human civilization,
all these years,
since the printing press,
since newspapers all these years,
it's television now.
All these years of the internet.
It's still that transparent.
It's still that
I gotta tell you though,
like I've been thinking lately about
seeing those images from Ukraine of all
of these people.
Bloody and they went total,
uh,
like completely off the civilization
map.
Just chaos burning stuff,
brother against brother,
like really dark shit over there.
And uh,
they threw out their president,
I believe,
and he's on the run or something.
But it makes me wonder,
like maybe some of this stuff that we
sense as being really oppressive is
necessary for society to just hold
together.
Like if we didn't have the occasional
situation where the government comes
down hard on somebody that things would
just slowly disintegrate and we will get
to a place where you walk into fedex and
nobody wants to.
Nobody wants to check you out because
there's not enough of thIs kind of
cohesive societal thing.
Well,
that's sort of the thinking that there
has to be a yin and a yang.
there has to be a good and an evil.
There has to be suppression and this
desire to escape suppression in order to
create momentum and energy and in order
to to enthusiastically encouraged
innovation,
you have to be fighting against
something.
You have to be battling against them.
Yeah.
It's almost like to discover freedom,
you have to face a little bit of
oppression.
Yeah.
There's a lot of thinking behind that,
that that's sort of the way the universe
works and that there's hunters and then
there's prey there.
You know,
there's lions and then there's gazelles
and that.
This is just sort of the way the world
works in order for the gazelles to stay
alive and keep reading.
They have to realize a lion coming after
them because if there was,
you know,
because gazelles could just hang out and
live in one spot.
They'd probably eat themselves silly.
They'd fucked so much.
There'd be too many of them.
Then they'd all die of starvation.
There would be no food left.
I mean it's almost like you need both.
You need a good and a bad and he did a
night and a day.
You need a winter and a summer.
You need a whole fucking lot of
different things to come into play.
Yeah,
well that's what I'm starting to think
is kind of evolving my views on this
stuff because I think that government
serves as a kind of immune system
against shit like what happened in
Ukraine and what's happening in parts of
south America now where people are just
losing it and you can't let that happen.
You just can't,
you know,
because the results,
you don't know where it ends and it
seems like at least the example with
Egypt,
it ends in a bad place.
You go from something that really sucks
to something that's unimaginably worse
and even more oppressive because you can
only go from oppression,
the chaos to more oppression.
It's very rare what the United States
did with our founding and the
constitution and the bill of rights.
These are very rare things that don't
happen all that often.
Interesting that we don't realize we
don't.
We didn't observe and learn from what
what,
what did we try to escape and what did
we pull off in trying to escape,
but what we pulled off is the greatest
startup civilization the world has ever
known from.
I mean,
without a doubt,
there's never been a time in human
history where within 300 years less of a
country being formed is become dominant
superpower on earth,
not not just in a roman sort of a way,
not in a gang is con sort of a way,
but in a truly global way.
And now we find out is spying on
everybody as well.
Has missiles all over the world sending
drones into places where they're not
supposed to invade.
So we send flying robots to do our dirty
work for us.
What mean it's the most insane
dictatorship or the most insane
government rather shouldn't say
dictatorship.
It kind of is,
you know,
it's the most insane.
If you look at the rest of the world,
they would think of us as,
you know,
dictators dominating them.
Well,
we occupy a unique space.
It's really the,
you know,
you read about this shit,
the pox americana and all that stuff
like we've imposed a worldwide piece.
I realize I'm using the word peace even
though there are people dying in certain
areas,
but it's essentially piece through force
and we've established that and I don't
want to say that that's all bad because
I think it's provided a lot of stability
and a lot of innovation for millions of
people.
It's not all bad.
Nothing is all bad,
but there's a lot of bad.
Right?
But What I was going to say is that what
we have become in this most insane
empire ever was it was all born out of
trying to escape suppression and we
tried to establish these parameters that
would avoid suppression in this place
and those parameters allowed people to
be free to do a lot of things that
weren't able to do in other countries to
freedom,
set up homesteads and build houses and
fucking farm and,
and,
and make cities that just don't exist
anywhere in the fucking world.
Why did New York city arise in,
in America?
I'd rub because it wasn't an another
fucking country like us.
When New York city was first formed,
there was nothing like us and everybody
flocked here from all over the fucking
planet knowing that this is the free
spot.
This is where my pArents,
my parents family came from.
They all came from Italy and they came
from Ireland where it sucked and they
got on boats.
They didn't even know what the fuck was
on the other end because there was no
internet back then and they just fucking
took a chance.
And those gangster mother fuckers
created this incredible place where they
were trying to escape a shit life.
So What do we do?
We shut up this life too.
We,
we,
we impose the same bullshit that we were
scared of or they were scared of when
they formed America.
We just fucking ignore it.
We ignore what,
what our founding fathers warned us
about and we think we're smarter than
that.
Well,
you know,
it benefits me if I take away the fourth
amendment.
So fuck you.
I'm just some fat guy who eats meat and
takes prozac.
And I've decided I'm going to change the
law.
Yeah,
it is kind of funny that we've in some
ways become what we run from.
It's like that greek myth where the king
is given the prophecy that uh,
his son one day will grow up to kill
him.
And so he exiles his son to some distant
land.
And in so doing,
he eventually assures his own death
because they're in a battle or something
and the sun kills his father not
realizing that it's his father.
And if he had actually just lived in the
kingdom for his whole life,
he of course would not kill his own dad,
but it was that very action of to
prevent his
fate that made it occur.
Yeah,
creating enemies,
creating enemies out of fear,
being afraid of people so you create an
enemy and then you create someone that
you should be afraid of,
but now and now we're drawing people and
creating new enemies.
Not just droning people,
but the latest revelation that we're not
just droning people what we're using
metadata to find out where their phones
are and sending missiles to where their
phones are.
Especially when it's been absolutely
shown that al qaeda and the taliban,
they switched sim cards back and forth
and move them around all the time so
that people can't clock where the phone
is connected.
Is it connected to this?
AlgerIa guy is connected to our
halloween because who knows?
It's a fucking sim cards floating
around.
Who knows who's got what,
but they decide that it's okay to shoot
missiles to where the phone is.
I mean,
that's.
That's some incredibly evil shit that's
insanely evil.
The idea that it's more important to
kill this guy than it is to not kill all
the innocent people around him.
Wow.
They probably turned on his camera
though in there listening first,
you know like,
oh,
nope.
That's him.
That's.
I could hear his voice.
Not according to the nsa documents.
They don't have any of the cooperating
evidence outside of the metadata.
Wow.
yeah.
They just knew where the phone was.
Sent a rocket there.
She'll pull them.
He's got a lot of these guys also use
phones that you can take the.
They don't have cash,
they won't use phones that have
batteries in them that you can't take
out.
Like they never use iphone or like htc
ones.
They use phones where you could always
take the battery out because the nsa and
you know,
whatever,
covering organizations fill in the
blank,
you know,
the mossad plucking the [inaudible] or
whatever.
They all at this point in time,
if you're a bad guy,
they have the capability of listening
into your phone calls.
They also have the capability of turning
on your cameras so they use specific
phones that don't have that.
Also you could remove batteries so they
don't have a power source and they'll,
you know,
they'll,
they'll cover their phone cameras,
the front facing camera and all kinds of
other shit too.
So they,
they,
they work around all that kind of stuff.
They're not,
they're not stupid to what technology
allows the enemy or their enemy to do,
but you know,
the metadata thing is just so crazy.
So yeah,
the idea that you found out where the
phone is,
so you send a missile to where that
phone is.
I mean,
I could sort of kind of see if,
you know,
this was your,
your,
you know,
it's godzilla and godzilla's phone is.
Yeah,
yeah.
I'd say just to,
just to be sure to send a missile that
way.
I still have trouble believing that
they're just killing people on the
metadata because uh,
I would like to think that there's
somebody within these agencies who's
like,
wait a second,
we got to actually have some kind of
probable cause here before we end
somebody's life.
Yeah.
It wOuld be nice to think that,
but the issue is that you're dealing
with people who are so accustomed to
making decisions that cost people
millions of lives.
I mean,
or you knoW,
over course of time,
millions of lives,
thousands of lives,
dozens of lives,
whatever it is,
the loss of life there are so accustomed
to making those decisions.
One of the things that came out of the,
uh,
the wikileaks,
it was so disturbing was the collateral
murder video where they were talking
about shooting those missiles into the
van and that there were children there
and then the guy was like,
fuck them.
You know,
it shouldn't have brought their kids.
Remember that?
Yeah,
I do.
I that wiki leaks is another example
where if they had just come out on day
one and said,
okay,
this organization has a surface,
some shit that is really unacceptable,
we're going to investigate it.
We're going to make sure it doesn't
happen again.
Thank you very much.
That would have been the end of it.
This whole thing with julian assange and
the embassy and wiki leaks becoming this
globally prominent,
whatever it is,
like this alternative media organization
would not have happened at all if the us
government on day one and just said,
okay,
thanks for bringing this stuff to our
attention.
It will not happen again.
Yeah,
but they don't want it to not happen
again.
They wanted to continue happening,
but they don't want to make sure that
they
in the age of the internet,
you can't just crack down on something
like wiki leaks so that a lot of people
noticing,
well now they know.
I mean now they know.
Now they know because of that and now
they know because of snowden.
I mean now they know,
but it was uncharted territory,
but the point I was making is,
you know,
saying that they wouldn't shoot missiles
to where the metadata is because they're
worried about innocent civilians and
casualties.
Will you clearly look at that video and
you could say,
at least in this certain circumstance,
there is a very flippant attitude about
the loss of collateralized collateral
damage and it's children.
They're talking about I shouldn't have
brought their kids like,
okay,
really?
Is that where we're at?
We're the good guys and they shouldn't
have brought their kids and that's,
that's the attitude.
Not all my god.
Did we kill kids.
There's not that attitude that it's
pretty indigenized.
It's unbelievably dehumanized and you
want to talk about innocent.
Guess what?
There's no one more innocent than
children.
They didn't choose to be there.
They didn't choose to be born there.
They didn't choose to have those parents
that didn't choose to be led by their
little tiny hands into the fucking car
seat in the van.
Where are you going to shoot with
hellfire missiles because you,
you thought a reporter was an assassin.
You know,
I mean,
it's all a mistake and their attitude
is,
hey,
we should have brought their kids.
That leads me to believe that there are
people out there in the world who are
willing to shoot missiles to where the
phone is.
Hmm.
It's so weird that with Vietnam they
went through all this stuff like the
slow realization that we're maybe not
supposed to be there and that innocent
people are being killed and there's no
purpose for this.
like we came to that realization with
Vietnam and it seems like a lot of the
same stuff is happening now and we're
going through the same bullshit where
you have to listen to people on tv tell
you that,
you know,
we got to support the troops.
We can't question anything.
We've already been there like that all
happened in the Vietnam war and then
eventually people just fell out of that
narrative and they realized it was
bullshit and now today it's still
considered something where you can't
just say that the wars are complete
bullshit.
Well,
the best story about all this or the
most ridiculous but yet true is that
both the Vietnam war and the Afghanistan
war,
a big part of what's going on,
is it profiting familial drugs?
I mean that was the heroin,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
heroin.
I mean there was a big part of what was
going on in Vietnam.
It was a big part of the whole golden
triangle.
I mean,
it was a big.
The,
the amount of money that was moved in
heroin during the Vietnam era is
documented.
I mean,
it's documented that there were soldiers
that were involved,
were profiting.
What was that movie with denzel
Washington where he,
uh,
he played a famous drug dealer that went
to,
uh,
to China and was,
he had a friend or one of his buddies
was a Vietnam.
I'm a soldier and they were,
they were based on a true story about
how uh,
he became a big time drug dealer.
American gangster.
Yeah.
That was it.
Great fucking movie.
I saw that movie.
It was much like,
what's going on in Afghanistan now?
you,
if you brought it up back then,
hey,
a big reason,
a big motivation for the Vietnam war is
a secret drug running organization.
They were like,
get out of here.
You fucking crack pot.
That's the same thing they say today,
but today it's even more blatant in your
face.
When geraldo rivera is interviewing
troops that are guarding poppy fields.
Like,
wait,
wait.
Right,
right,
right.
What,
what are you doing?
Well,
we need the information from these
people and where the taliban is,
so we're going to guard their poppy
fields.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
No one's making any money off this
though,
right?
Yeah.
The fuck outta here.
Whoever it is that's profiting on
whatever by whatever method,
whatever avenue they're profiting,
they find some sort of a Justification
for it,
but make no mistake about it.
Part of the motivation and why we're
there is that money that has a factor.
I don't know what factor it is.
Is it more or less valuable than the
trillions of dollars in minerals they
have discovered?
Is it more or less valuable than the
natural gas at that Russia and the
United States were duking it out over
during the time of the mujahideen is,
is it more or less?
I don't know,
but it's a factor.
It's unquestionably a factor.
The amount of heroin production in
Afghanistan since he knew us occupation,
is that like 90 percent or something
fucking crazy through the roof.
So this is just the unreported,
a sister story.
It's facts.
I mean,
these are facts,
stone cold.
No,
When I say unreported,
not saying that this shit's not true.
what I'm saying is like,
this is the stuff that people don't see
on fox and friends exactly is the poppy
fields.
Uh,
it's kind of interesting that we watch
fox or msnbc and some kind of academic.
Uh,
we'll talk about obama's performance is
if obama is just this country,
a politician who we can just sit there
and review him,
but he's really this incredibly powerful
near emperor of what you just talked
about,
this technological and military empire.
And so it's kind of absurd I think for
us to still think that he's this
constitutionally bound president.
I mean,
he's spying on all these people.
We've got military actions all over the
world.
Like we need to consider the fact that
we are not living in a pre nine slash 11
world anymore.
The,
um,
opium production,
it's ramped up 49 percent from 2012.
It goes up all the time.
It's just going up and up.
It sounds like the business to be in.
Yeah.
It's way better than bitcoin right now.
To bitcoin into poppy seeds,
it's,
it's incredible.
If you look at,
if just google the,
uh,
amount that heroin has,
has jumped up 50.
Oh my god,
it's up by 50 percent in the last year.
This is the most recent january of 2014.
That's from newsweek.
By the way.
It's crazy that from news week their
drug output is up 50 percent in the last
year and since the.
Since the american takeover,
since american occupation,
let me google that american occupation,
it's full or that,
that's some nutty number.
Oh god.
It's just so sad because it's so
obvious.
It's so in our face,
you know?
Do you think that the world getS better?
I think I asked you this last time,
but from here I feel like thingS have to
get better and they're already getting
better.
There are definitely better,
but I think whAt we're getting at
earlier is really important that the yin
and the yang is almost necessary in
order for things to get done.
And it seems to be almost a natural part
of the universe.
I think this is the greatest time ever
to be alive or really do,
but I think every time was the greatest
time ever to be alive at that time.
You know,
just not everywhere.
If you live in africa right now,
if you're in Liberia right now,
it fucking socks is a sucky time to be
alive.
You know,
if you live in Somalia and you have to
be a pirate because all the europeans
have dumped nuclear waSte off your
shores and killed all the fish.
Very sucky time to be Alive.
You're basically living in a mad max
movie.
You're living in the apocalypse here.
A bunch of skinny guys on cat that
fucking,
that narcotic that they chew leaves to
get amphetamine.
Not ma'am.
Now,
now it's called cat k,
h a t.
It's a type of amphetamine that they,
uh,
they get from plants and they chew it.
They get whacked out of their fucking
mind and they get machine guns and they
get in rowboats and they go full over
fucking oil tankers and the worst
combination of things ever.
So worse combination of things ever.
And you know,
for them It's terrible time to be alive,
but for us here in los angeles chilling,
drinking fucking oh,
coconut water,
it's pretty nice.
Can god's greatest weed sitting here
using laptops and super powerful
internet connection connected to a
million people in the world.
It's awesome.
It's an awesome time to be alive.
It is.
And I love,
I love America and I love the internet
and that's part of the reason why I'm so
obsessed with all the shit I talk about
is that these are really cool tools that
we've put out into the world and it kind
of pains me to see us fucking it up.
Right?
Like we created the internet and it's
truly amazing.
It's a game changer and no,
now we've weaponized it.
That's the phrase they use,
you just showed.
Yeah,
where you're using it to harass innocent
people and credit them.
Ruined their business people.
I am going to get thIs a million times
now that I've talked about that,
which is will aren't companies doing
that aren't individuals trolling.
And I'm like,
it's really different when the
government is using your tax dollars
that you send them every year and
they're using that to psychologically
harass you or to harass the journalists
that you listened to.
That's really dIfferent from some
fucking weirdo doing it are some greedy
company doing because they want to just
protect their little domain.
But those companies that do do it,
they're full of shit.
You should avoid them.
They're shitty if you,
if you're,
if you're saying negative
things about the competition and you're
making them up and you're trolling and
you're trying to kill their business,
you're a shithead.
You know what I mean?
That's reality.
You know?
Um,
there's a,
a thing that's been going on with us
with,
uh,
one of the guys that we've had on the
podcast several times,
guy named dave asprey,
who I don't hate.
I like the gUy,
I think he's a good guy.
I think he's flawed.
Like a lot of human beings.
I'm flawed as well,
but he's exaggerated and said some
things on the show that have turned out
to bite us in the ass.
And I sorta started investigating it
because he started making claims about
my friend tate's business.
Tate started taping him.
we're going to go into business
together.
Uh,
for whatever reason they had a falling
out.
So tate decided to start selling his own
coffee.
Dave asprey sells a bunch of things,
sells a good products,
good coffee,
a bunch of other different health and
nutrition products.
Nothing wrong with what he's selling,
but he started shooting on tate stuff.
He called it inferior quality without
any testing whatsoever.
And then you also called it a knock off.
He's talking about is mct oil that he
sells.
Well,
here's the problem with that.
Several problems.
One problem being that dave asprey
doesn't make mct oil.
He buys it because a company that buy
it,
they buy and they sell it to a bunch of
different companies.
My friend larry used to be in the
nutrition business and he was uh,
he owned a company called nature's pure,
a very good company.
And he told me exactly how it all works
and he told me how he buys from the same
suppliers that all these other people
buy from.
LIke there's,
there's only a limited amount of
suppliers that make vitamin d that make
mct or they'll make all these different
things.
You buy it from them,
you try to buy from the most reputable
supplier and then you package it
yourself and label it yourself.
That's what dave does and that's what
tate did too.
And so dave was called tate stuff
inferior without any testing whatsoever.
That's a propensity for bullshitting and
so I saw that and I was like,
what the fuck is that man?
you can't do that.
You can't just say that because I know
where you get your shit.
I know the company that makes your stuff
so you can't just say that his stuff is
inferior.
We don't know where he buys it.
You don't know what testing is done.
You don't know.
In fact,
I even went out of the way to make his
is mct oil to try to improve what he
thought dave was doing by selling it in
glass bottles because he felt like
plastic can leach.
It can leach chemicals.
It's,
it's,
it's in the heat,
like it's very conscientious the way you
did it.
What was not so conscientious with that,
he kind of copied dave's business model.
He copied dave's claims about mycotoxins
and all these different things,
so then he goes and tests dave's coffee
and then test his coffee as well.
Well,
dave's coffee turns out to test positive
for under threshold below threshold of
two different mycotoxins means you're
not going to affect you,
it's not going to physically affect you,
but his whole claim to fame was that
there's a real issue with mycotoxins and
coffee.
He's developed a process that elIminates
them.
Every other coffee could be tainted.
That was his number one thing.
It's like classic government shit,
create a problem and then offer a
solution.
So I know parrot his words not doing any
research,
you know,
and having them on the podcast.
He's a very smart guy,
very knowledgeable.
It seems so.
We repeat is his words about mycotoxins
and coffee.
So tate,
when he does this test and finds out the
dave stuff actually has mycotoxins and
tate's,
which has gone through none of this
super secret process.
He's just done the standard wet
processing that all high level single
source coffee companies do take,
you know,
he goes,
well,
what the fuck man,
you know,
this guy's shit has some mycotoxins mind
doesn't like w w what exactly is going
on here?
So we sell his coffee at on it.
We sell the bulletproof coffee or
upgraded coffee,
asprey's coughing.
So we decided to test that and tate's
and starbucks and some random coffee
from whole foods.
None of them test positive for
mycotoxins.
So it's an instant issue that's not
really presents an issue,
but we've been parenting it and,
and saying that it becomes this huge
thing saying that it's an issue saying
that it's a huge health issue,
but every coffee expert you read online
thinks it's bullshit.
They all think it's bullshit.
In fact,
there's like scores that they have for
coffee.
They have scores like a really good
coffee,
like rusty's hawaiian that we started
drinking.
It's a really good stuff and it's scored
like a 95.
It's delicious coffee,
you know?
And in order to score high,
they test your stuff from mold.
Like they test it,
they,
you can't have moldy coffee and have a
test high.
So iT's,
this is not an issue.
This isn't an issue that was existing in
the eighties.
There's a pub med or article from 1980
about mycotoxins.
So people aren't,
people aren't dying or chopping other
people's faces off a bunch of other shit
about it.
Like it causes coffee to be bitter.
That's not the case.
That's not true.
So there's a lot of.
So my point is this all started his,
his whole downfall started because he
was making false claims to try to
eliminate competition.
he was doing exactly what we're seeing
companies shouldn't do,
shouldn't shit on someone to eliminate
competition.
Now if aspe came out and said,
hey,
you know,
I think it's kind of fucked up to tate
is basically copying my,
my claims about mycotoxins,
which by the way aren't true.
Then he would have a point,
but it would say,
hey,
you take the copy of my lies.
You know?
I mean that's basically what he would
have to say because other than that,
there's not really case.
Other than that,
it's just the the,
the coffee equivalent of a root beer
float,
which is coffee with butter and mct oil,
which then it turns out that wasn't even
asked his idea.
It was a guy named rob wolf.
Another guy we've had on the podcast,
one of the paleo gurus.
He wrote about it in 2004,
so it wasn't asked for idea.
This idea had been out there.
He collects these ideas and that's one
of the things that rhonda patrick,
who was on last week because a phd,
she said that after he put some shit on
his website from her scientific research
with vitamin d and didn't accreditor,
so there's a lot of that going on,
man.
A lot of people discrediting people sang
shitty things about being a know.
It all comes back to get that.
It all comes back because if you're
saying false claims about someone like
that,
if you're.
If you're just randomly deciding that
someone's stuff is shit,
well then they get to test your stuff
too,
man,
and if it turns out that your whole
process is bullshit,
that all this unnecessary nonsense or
voodoo you're doing to your,
your,
your process to make sure that your
stuff is better than everybody else's.
It doesn't actually work is actually
real and the problem doesn't actually
exist.
Yeah.
Then you shouldn't throw stones if
you're in the glass.
The glass house.
If he didn't do that,
we would have never tested his coffee.
We would have thought that it was
probably still an issue.
You can find things online about
mycotoxins in coffee,
been an issue,
but apparently they figured it out in
like the 19 eighties,
this wet processing they figured out so
you know,
it puts us in a real bad position
because we've said what this guy said,
we repeated it on this podcast.
I've repeated it and you know,
it's not a bad product.
Everything.
He sells his good stuff.
Don't make any mistake about it.
It's not.
You shouldn't,
not by dave as that's not his style.
Know that is a hawaiian roasters,
that's a different one,
or it's caveman.
It was that cayman or hawaiian roasters,
hawaiian roasters,
which we have no affiliation with.
Cave man is.
My friend hates coffee.
I have no business interest in that.
He's just my friend.
Um,
you know,
I actually have a business interest in
selling asprey's coffee because I own a
piece of art and I sell it through on
it,
but I,
you know,
I have to be honest always about
everything and I,
I would have like,
it would be profitable for me to not
talk about this because we sell his
coffee,
but it's not ethical.
Yeah.
Meanwhile,
it's good coffee.
It's nothing wrong with it.
People caffeinated,
which is necessary.
It's good.
He,
he,
he buys very good coffee.
He sells very good coffee.
There's absolutely nothing wrong with
it.
The other,
the claims were unnecessary and the
claims created a business and they
created a model.
They created this,
this,
this issue that doesn't seem to exist,
but why did it all come out to light?
What all came to light?
Because there was unfair claims about
someone that he thought was a
competitor,
I mean,
and that's that country shit that the
government is encouraging their
employees to do,
to discredit people is what discredits
the government when something like that.
yeah.
That's like the perfect way of
expressing what I was trying to get at
earlier.
This idea of you're the fucking
government and you're the us president.
Uh,
you don't,
you can't,
you can't lower yourself to this level
where you're competing with snowden,
with a back and forth.
That should be.
We fucked up where the government,
we're going to correct it.
Yes.
Everybody would honor that.
The same with wikileaks.
The same with guantanamo bay,
like we went overboard with some
interrogation stuff.
We detained some people against their
rights,
their basiC rights.
We did this because we were panicked and
we didn't want another nine slash 11 and
now we'll take steps to correct it.
And that's not what they're saying and
that's not what they're doing.
And that's really,
I think all anybody wants to hear that,
that kind of rhetoric from here on out,
which is we recognize there's a problem.
They've never fucking Said that,
yes,
obama as many positive things is that I
can say about obama as I grow,
to just learn more about the world and
realize that he's not this evil dictator
that info wars makes them out to be it's
more complex.
Picture.
With thAt said,
he still has not come out and said,
it's clear at this point the nsa has
done some stuff that is not within the
bounds of our laws and we'll fix that
and that's all he'd have to do and it'd
be
close to the most people would demand.
What does fix that mean?
The most have locked about clamping down
on it now and those people will be okay
though.
I think you're always gonna have this
symbolism.
no.
Does that mean you would be okay
if I honestly believed that obama was
fixing the problem in a meaningful way?
I'd be okay with it because I'm very
busy and I don't want to nitpick.
Well,
I'd rather see us move forward as a
country and not continue to.
You can go after anything until the end
of time.
There are some really big innovations
ahead of us,
I think where we might go into a big
economic boom in the next few years.
The bitcoin thing,
even if bitcoin goes away,
something very similar to it is going to
take off and these are exciting things
like we're on the verge of another big
tech boom.
Like we were in the nineties.
We shouldn't get bogged down with all
this petty bickering and all this
hateful stuff and red vs blue and
petty at all.
I think it's critical.
I think it's a sign of the times and I
think it's indicative of this new
environment that we find ourselves in
this new environment.
No,
I don't mean the issues are petty.
I mean the government back and forth is
petty.
It's very petty to like force an
airplane to the ground to search for
somebody.
This is not,
this is the most powerful government,
the world you shouldn't behave like.
I agree with that.
I absolutely agree with that.
I.
But I think what's going on,
you know,
whether we're talking about that,
uh,
the,
the coffee thing or whether we're
talking about the government thing or
the talk about virtually anything is you
can't expect to get away with business
as usual because there's too much that
gets exposed now because of the
internet.
I think that when you do evil shit and
other people are aware of that evil shit
and they could find out about that evil
shit and put it online.
You know,
you got to expect that you can't,
you can't keep these nsa workers silent
because a lot of them are actual
patriots.
You know,
they might have,
they might have gotten a job a long time
ago out of college working for the nsa,
but they didn't do it because they
wanted to be a bad guy.
They didn't do it because they wanted to
spy on their neighbor because their
neighbor mike just think that the United
States should get the fuck out of
Afghanistan.
You know,
tHat's not why they did it.
They did it because they wanted to keep
people safe.
There's a lot of people like that out
there,
so they find themselves a part of this
genuinely dangerous organization that is
genuinely violating constitutional
rights and what do they do?
They take chances.
They take.
What about that
william binney guy,
that guy?
That was the first a whistleblower.
Way,
way,
way back in the day.
That guy had some balls.
That guy had some balls and he got away
with it too because he was just
predicting a future crime.
He quit and then he predicted a future
crime and then when the future crime
actually came into manifestation,
we can't.
it manifested itself.
That was like 10 years later.
It's pretty incredible.
When you stop and think about it.
This guy called it and he quit the nsa
after 2001 that has amazing.
Fuck.
That's amazing.
He was the original was a whistleblower
and nobody talks about that cat,
that guy.
I mean he.
He's another fucking hero.
What they're doing is what you're not
supposed to do.
You're not supposed to do it like that.
You have an obligation.
You're the top of the heap,
but I think it's also an impossible job.
I think trying to govern 300 million
people is impossible and I think you'd
get frustrated.
It's where most come up with all these
ways to keep these motherfuckers in
check.
That's where my president obama may be
right article comes from,
is this realization that there are a lot
of people and actually the best
description of obama that I've heard,
there's this pickup artists who put some
of his videos on youtube and they're not
all about pickup.
A lot of them are just about like views
on life.
Who's this?
Uh,
this guy,
oh,
and cook.
He actually lives in la,
but I've never met him.
And uh,
I was watching this video where he was
like,
people aren't really prepared to hear
the truth about obama,
which is that he's kind of like a,
a principal for this school known as the
United States.
So he's just trying to hold shit
together and people don't want him to go
up on the podium and say,
look,
you want more jobs?
You've got to create some innovation
because things are stagnant,
like you've got to go out there and do
it.
I can't just create things out of thin
air and it's the same with national
security stuff.
He can't fix everything that people need
to demand,
you know,
protections of their privacy's.
It's not all on him.
It has to be on the people and I think
that we,
for the most part,
not uni,
not red band,
not most of the listeners,
but in fucking lazy as a country,
been focused on other stuff and now it's
kind of coming back to bite us in the
ass.
So we have to decide like what's
important to us,
how far are we willing to trade off our
basic rights in exchange for the
guarantee of no more nine slash 11.
Yeah,
I mean,
or does that even work at all?
And what should we concentrate on when
we're trying to prevent another nine
slash 11?
What should we concentrate on?
Should we concentrate on spying on
americans or should we concentrate on a
non intervention is an interventional
foreign policy that doesn't cause people
to get so fucking pissed off at us that
they want to kill us.
Should we concentrate on not shooting
dji drones into apartment buildings
because they have a fucking cell phone
that we want to find the user
maybe focused on not giving easy,
easy,
uh,
immigration rights to fucking Saudi
Arabia when like all the nine slash 11
hijackers,
I believe are from Saudi Arabia or many
of them were.
There's got to be a bunch of different
things that could be done.
However,
the problem is so gigantic.
The world is so enormous.
There are so many people.
There's so many competing financial
factors.
There's so much shit going on that,
for any one group to try to fix it and
they don't even work together,
which is so fucked up.
The cia and the fbi don't work
together.
And pete with each other,
right?
There's competition.
WeLl,
that's how it portrays got busted.
They got busted because the fucking cia
was getting investigated by the fbi.
They investigated,
portray as the fbi investigated,
portrays the fucking head spook got
spooked on.
I mean that's how we got busted.
That's how they found out about his
affair.
I think women is really how he got
busted though.
He allowed his personal life to take
over.
Yes.
Granted,
I know absolutely nothing about this
case,
but just from what little I know,
it seems like that's not something that
would have happened if he had remained
100 percent above board.
That whole investigation that was set
off by the fbi would have never happened
because it was that woman in tampa,
the socialite or whatever,
who triggered the whole fucking
unraveling thing and once you unleash
those kinds of forces,
I think they just keep digging until
they.
Until they find something to crankin
yeah.
It's a cracking.
You unleash that beast and you know,
knowing where it'll end up and it ended
up with him losing his job.
Well,
isn't it hilarious too that he lost his
job because of pussy.
He's the number one murderer in the
country.
I mean he's basically,
that's what it is.
He murders bad guys for the country.
That's what a general is.
I mean,
you don't want to say no murder.
Let's say killer.
Let's say eliminator.
Let's,
let's sanitize it.
He's,
he's a warrior warrior.
Let's say warrior.
He's the head warrior.
Just go back to like the conan the
barbarian books,
or watch a movie.
What it kona and do he slayed and he
fucked.
That's what warriors do.
They slay and they fuck.
So we want these neutered warriors.
We want these warriors that don't.
Fuck.
We want these,
these people that are over there just
shooting the heads off of people from a
distance.
Watch their heads explode and they don't
get any pussy.
They're,
they're stopping life on a regular
basis,
doing what?
There's laWs against what the bible
tells you you can't do,
but the bible,
you don't have to worry about the bible
because you got a free pass from uncle
sam.
We've talked to god and god says it's
okay to kill these folks as long as
well.
W,
what if we went into Iraq on a false
premise?
God will forgive you.
I know you kill those people for no
reason,
but hey,
um,
you didn't know any better,
so it's all good.
Well then who's to blame?
No one's to blame because the government
is essentially like a gigantic
corporation that doesn't have real,
sort of like one person that you could
pin it to is like a lot of people and
whatever,
whatever.
Don't worry about it dude.
I mean that's essentially what's going
on.
So that one guy who's the best general
patraeus,
he's the guy,
there's the guy that whenever they went
to the news and if there's something
Afghanistan thing,
they went to general patraeus,
he can't get some pussy.
Really?
You're going to,
you're going to hAte him because I look
for his marriage vows aside.
Of course his wife,
she'd be upset if she didn't know.
Of course,
you know,
if he lied about it.
That's kind of something to take into
consideration when you factor in his
character,
taken into consideration lightly when
you really stop and think about how many
warriors in the past have had harems and
gingiss con fucked like every living
human being in the year 12 slash 20.
I mean w w,
what are we pretending,
pretending these warriors are we
pretending that they're,
you know,
some strange barbie doll can gi joe,
Oregon list thing that just fights for
god,
glory and country and doesn't have
physical desires.
I was a awhile ago,
I had this guy,
David Brennan on my podcast and he was
talking about how police and militaries
and stuff,
I've only been professional flight the
last hundred and 20 years or something
before that,
they were just pretty much the enforcers
for whoever owned the land.
So if you were the feudal lord,
you would have your own police force who
had basically collect taxes and beat
peasants and stuff.
We've only expected police and soldiers
to be pr professional for the past
hundred years.
So there's still kind of catching up
because these are very old structures
and you're using violence,
so it's hard to.
How do you mix?
It's always kind of boggled my mind that
cops will go from a fatal,
like some kind of fatal confrontation
where they have to take somebody down to
15 minutes later they're at starbucks
getting another coffee.
Like that's gotta be a weird fucking
mind melt.
It's a,
they have a massive disconnect and I
think it may very well be that a lot of
them were taking antidepressants.
I know antidepressants in the military,
incredibly common.
It's one of the most prescribed
medications for people that come back.
They have ptsd and people have issues
and depressant.
Well,
let's google that because,
um,
I read an article recently about
antidepressants in the military and I
don't remember the exact statistics,
but it was in the military.
It was pretty disturbing,
but makes sense because they allow you
to rationalize things in a way that
you're not going to if you're not on
that stuff.
Yeah.
Man.
Antidepressants in the military.
Yeah,
there's a lot.
There's a lot.
Man.
Military prescribes antidepressants to
growing army of soldiers.
Okay.
Military says at 12 percent of its
combat personnel in Iraq and 17 percent
serving in Afghanistan are taking
prescription antidepressants.
This is for 2008.
I can only assume the numbers have gone
up.
Sure.
It's increased since then.
Of course it has.
If they found out there's money in it,
they look.
That's the beautiful thing about being a
corporation.
You have to maximize your profits every
year.
Corporations just can't stay.
Hey,
we made x amount of money last year and
we made the same this year,
so we're doing really good guys.
No,
no.
You have to continue to grow.
They want that infinite growth paradigm
that I'm Peter Joseph always goes on and
on about and his documentaries.
I mean,
that's one of the most ridiculous
aspects of corporations.
One of the most ridiculous aspects of
the economy is the infinite growth idea.
The idea that you can just continue to
get bigger and bigger every year until
what you have all the money on the
planet because that's where it goes.
If every fucking corporation actually
continued to grow and,
and,
and stayed alive for 100,
50,
350,
a thousand years,
whatever it takes,
they should all have all the money in
the world.
I mean,
what,
what happens then?
You can have infinite growth.
It doeSn't make sense.
It's a monopoly game.
Somebody ends up with all the pieces of
paper by end,
right?
So if you know,
you got to think that if the
pharmaceutical companies were making
untold millions of dollars in having 12
percent of the soldiers in Iraq and 17
percent in Afghanistan in 2008,
I mean,
that was six years ago.
So what Is it now?
You know,
it's probably pretty fucking crazy.
Let's see.
Any precedence in the military in 2014.
Let's try that.
Two thousand 14 and let's see what it
says.
Meanwhile,
by the way,
I'm just reading random blogs with a
very quick and cursory google search
with no vetting out whatsoever.
So they might be all full of shit.
But look,
we don't even have to look into it.
Whatever the numbers are,
those are all abstract anyway.
We know that It's a,
it's people.
People are definitely on it and that's
kind of crazy that you,
uh,
you know,
you take people and you put them in this
terrible situation.
He yanked them out of their lives and
you've,
you know,
you send them over to these,
now they've got to kill people and then
they come home and yeah,
their wife is sleeping with somebody
else or their girlfriend has left them
and then they have the ptsd crack,
crack down,
can't deal with life anymore.
I know a dude who,
um,
they just recently shot a guy and I know
he was having some ptsd issues.
I don't know what the exact
circumstances were.
There was a car accident.
Someone rear ended him and he wound up
shooting some guy.
Wow.
Yeah.
And I don't know.
He's,
you know,
he hasn't gone to court yet about it.
I know that they're trying to put
together the case and try to figure out
what the exact circumstances where the
guy rear ended him.
Who knows.
The guy might've been crazy,
who knows?
And he might've really been defending
himself.
Who knows?
I don't know,
but that's an issue when people are used
to killing people and people have been
over there for a while.
This guy,
he did a tour more than one and then he
also went back and did black water
stuff.
So without a doubt he's seen some shit.
You've seen dirty wars by now,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's pretty disturbing the.
Yeah,
it is.
Yeah.
Um,
I'm trying to get that guy on the
podcast.
I was actually watching summit last
night.
Jeremy scahill.
Yeah.
Um,
I think,
um,
you know,
we're,
we're living in a strange time where a
guy can make a documentary like that,
you know,
we're living in a strange time where you
could talk about documentary like that
for hours and hours.
Your podcast or this product
as part of the.
It's part of the reason I love America
as we can always self correct.
Yeah.
We're not doing this podcast in a
basement somewhere.
Worried about the fucking syrian army
storming in here and torturing us like
they are just,
if you're in a different part of the
world,
the only difference is you're in a
different area.
Yeah.
You no longer have these rights and you
gotta be careful.
We thankfully don't have that and I want
to,
I want to see that remain.
Obviously
I do too,
and I think that it's not just America,
it's a world and I think the idea of a
country like America,
I think ultimately the goal would be to
have the whole world up to the same
standard that we hold ourselves to and
have a global community of people that
are essentially,
you could have the same rights
everywhere you go and there's no
oppressive north korean regime is.
There's no places like Syria that's
still hold.
There's no places that
I think it's really shameful that we
haven't gone in North Korea yet because
I understand people are like,
what can we do?
We've got to do something.
It's a humanitarian disaster like
humanity basically watching another
holocaust.
Nobody wants to take the uh,
nobody wants to take the loss on it
because it's going to be messy and it's
going to take time and money and
probably going to lose some.
There's going to be,
well,
South Korea is going to lose.
That's our ally and that's a real issue
because it's right there.
But I don't think as a modern society,
we can see all this shit on the
internet.
We can't just let them continue to kill
people.
The other,
I think the other month he uh,
his girlfriend,
he just wiped out like all of her family
or friends or some shit over some
nonexistent.
A sligHt.
Well,
he executed his ex wife.
Is that what it was?
He executed his ex girlfriend and uh,
he executed his uncle who is thinking
about establishing a coo.
And then he executed all of his uncle's
family.
He executed his uncle's sons who were
innocent and they were 20 years old,
but he knew that they would come back to
get him one day.
So he executed them.
He executed everyone.
Meanwhile,
the us government is fixated on guys
like kim.com.
why don't they go after this fucking guy
in North Korea?
very good point.
Use the same kind of resources against
somebody like that rather than someone
who's a,
you know,
I would be concerned with military
operations because it's so close to
South Korea and I think they've publicly
stated that they would launch nukes at
South Korea if there were ever invaded.
We're,
we're so clever.
If there was some kind of resource we
wanted in North Korea,
we would find.
We would find a diplomatic way to
resolve it.
Okay.
But are we or are we not?
I mean we have to decide are we retarded
or we goofy fucks that do stupid shit
that we could point out easily.
Or are we these super clever geniuses
that know how to circumvent any security
systems?
I think,
I think halt the nukes.
I think that we are a,
we're convenient if the core
really smart,
but we have all these layers of
stupidity and not all of the layers are
connected.
Some of it is just stupidity.
It's not there for any reason,
you know?
I don't know.
You know,
I don't know what the answer is.
I don't know what our reaL capabilities
are and I probably shouldn't know since
I'm not in the military,
you know,
I would just,
I would love to be able to trust them
wholeheartedly.
I would love to,
would love to be able to step back and
say,
hey,
you know,
if they're invading a country because
that country is filled with fucking
assholes and those assholes are going to
kill innocent people worldwide.
I would love that.
I really would love that.
And I'm not an anti military guy.
I'm a realist.
I'm a realist when it comes to human
nature and I'm a realist when it comes
to human history.
If you look at the world,
there's never been a time of peace ever
in the entire world,
ever from the time that we were shut out
of the first monkey mama,
until you know,
fighting over a fucking deer leg or
whatever the hell we were fighting over
back then to today.
There's never been one day on earth
where no one died.
where no one dropped a rock on someone's
head from the top of a cliff.
There's never been one day on earth
where people didn't fight to the death.
It's always happened.
it's always been a part of what we are
and like the yin and the yang that we
were discussing earlier that sort of
exist in as a,
a natural part of just life in the
universe.
There's this push and there's,
this
does tie,
goes in.
The tide goes out.
Bill o'reilly can't explain that.
You can't explain that I'm in jesus his
corner.
But I think that there's,
there's something to that.
And there's something also to something
that I harp on quite often,
but I think it's an important point.
We'd like to look at all the different
sort of areas of the world where
there's,
what we call natural phenomenon or
natural examples of strange behavior or
observed behavior or,
um,
natural cycles of whether it's a weather
patterns or whether it's,
you know,
whatever it is.
We lOok at all these things as being
very natural except for ourselves.
For whatever reason,
when it comes to human beings,
we decided that because we're sentient,
because we're,
we have the ability to rationalize and
think and communicate.
We don't think what we do is natural
when we think,
well we do is just some,
well,
you know,
as a society we have to be civilized and
think things through and that might all
be natural.
It wouldn't.
We might be seeing with humanity is a
really complicated version of what goes
on in an anthill will we might be
seeing.
It's just some really natural behavior
that's just on some next level,
fractal shit.
It's just so uber complicated because
there's so many of us and you're dealing
in,
you're factoring in information as well
as the instincts to breed the instincts
to dominate and have food and resources
on top of all those other things.
You're also dealing with communication.
You're dealing with the ability to
exchange information.
Also the ability to enhance yourself
with that exchanged information and
alter perspectives.
A wolf stays a wolf.
It's whole life.
You give a douchebag.
Some mushrooms,
he becomes a really introspective
person.
At least for a few hours.
He'd become a yoga instructor,
was enough times.
Yeah,
I mean there's a lot of people that
changed because of experiences and
information and,
and,
and just life,
giving them something that forces them
to examine the,
the box that they put the world in life
gives them something that they've,
they've sort of been forced to sort of
get a new perspective that doesn't
happen in the animal world and that's
why you have to add in and factor in all
these variables and look at human beings
and say it seems natural.
What we're doing seems natural.
And I think that along with,
you know,
uh,
bears male bears eating the young cubs
to force the female to keep breeding.
I mean all that stuff is natural too.
It just,
it's,
it's disgusting and horrible to watch,
but it's all natural.
We're working it out,
we're working it out.
We are working it out.
I really think we are.
Um,
but I'm,
I'm confident about it.
I'm confident about it because the
effects in my own life of,
of education.
And when I say education,
I mean formal.
I mean,
just reading things and being exposed to
information and be exposed to wife
experience,
just doing this fucking podcast man,
just talking to people like yourself,
just having conversations with people
and hashing things out and then seeing
the reactions to these conversations
that people have online where they join
in.
They started discussing things on
twitter,
discussing things on facebook.
I've seen people you know,
have conversations in person about
things that have happened on the
podcast.
Well,
hey,
you know,
I,
I found out about this and then I
started researching into this and then I
changed my diet because of that and then
this and that and this and that.
It's one of the reasons why
misinformation like the aspe thing so
frustrating and it really pisses me off
because it's in.
It's in the wrong spirit of this thing.
It's in the wrong spirit of what we're
trying to.
You do?
Yeah.
You shouldn't have a scarcity mindset.
Everybody.
Coffee's a fucking huge market.
Everybody can have a piece.
Well,
famine thinking doesn't have any logic
attached to it.
Fam and thinking is just.
It is what it is.
I got to piss again.
Powerful piss again.
Well,
we're going to play the godzilla trailer
is something about it.
It's delicious by the way.
Stock and cto eIther.
They're just nice people.
We like them to play the godzilla
trailer because it looks dope as fuck.
And bryan cranston from breaking bad is
a fucking star.
It's gonna be epic.
God damn,
this looks good.
I want to talk to somebody in charge.
You're not fooling anybody when you say
that.
What happened was a natural disaster.
You're lying.
It was not an earthquake.
It wasn't a typhoon because what's
really happening is that you're hiding
something out,
by the way,
is the greatest promoted back to the
stove ever had been so good at releasing
shit.
Slowly
pop It right up on the ocean.
If you're listening and watching,
you're seeing a bunch of cool shit.
Your tests in the pacific.
No idea what's coming.
They're so good about not showing you
much to kill it.
Control
and not the other way around.
There's the arrogance of man,
so godzilla is coming next as well.
That would unite us.
This motherfucker popped out of the
ocean for sure.
This looks really good luck yet.
Please god,
don't let it suck.
Oh yeah,
baby.
My dick is rock hard and it is good
disaster point right there.
Fuck it is.
I love a good monster movie.
There's not enough.
So thanks to Ronald Greene of cto,
coconut water for keeping us with
coconut water that made david seaman
piss not once,
but twice.
And the three hour podcasts.
I'm a kid times,
man.
It was a fun podcast,
but yeah,
this is fun.
Um,
uh,
does anything that people need to know?
Anything you've got going on your
podcast is how they get it.
David seaman,
our itunes,
itunes.
Anything else that on stitcher as well?
No,
I'm not really promoting anything right
now.
So it's not on stitcher.
Oh,
it's on stitcher.
Yellow.
I just saved me like other projects.
No,
no,
but it's on stitcher.
It is available.
It's just straight mp3 format as well,
so they don't have to get it off of
itunes.
Exactly.
They want that.
They can just google david seaman hour
and it's like the first or second.
Please don't make fun of his name.
Okay.
The kid grew up with david seaman.
I like it.
Now.
It's one of those things that you're
uncomfortable about at middle school
because it's still so new to you as a 28
year old guy will turn into 28 next
week.
Like I'm kind of over the whole last
name is [inaudible] thing like good for
you.
Whatever you know.
And what's wrong with them?
Nothing.
The bedrock of human society makes
humans,
you know,
it's like a cement.
Whatever buildings.
It's memorable,
which I like.
If your name was David Steele,
no problem.
What a steel makes still makes
buildings.
Everybody wants to come.
Nothing wrong with come.
Definitely.
Because if your name was david seaman in
your mouth,
then we'd have an issue if you need to
change.
My last name was david seaman in your
mouth and you're a guy.
Like if that was like the full name.
Hi,
my name is David Stevenson in your
mouth.
And I'm a guy.
Yeah,
I do a name change.
I'd be like a smith and my parents are
just fucking assholes.
Uh,
let's,
let's change her last name,
but dick in the ass when he.
Kanye west,
name is kidd north north.
That's not too bad.
I thought it was weird.
Weird.
It's annoying.
It's egocentric.
It's gross.
He'll regret it when it's kid fucking
susan gets older.
Not that that's going to happen.
Um,
so the david seaman,
our david seaman,
our,
the last guest was the ceo of a bitcoin
exchange and I grilled him on whether
it's good time to buy.
So I'm totally hypocritical because I
had never had a problem with moon unit
zappa.
If I didn't have a problem with moon
unit zappa.
Why do I care about northwest?
I had apologized.
Kanye.
You're righT,
man.
Nothing wrong with northwest.
That's good.
If you will.
I didn't have a problem.
If you didn't apologize right there,
he'd probably be tweeting you in a few
hours with a obtain rogan.
He's allowed to sit the man.
He's the biggest rOck star fall.
Anyway.
If you're a geniuS,
you have to acknowledge that you're a
genius.
Exactly.
You have to.
You're not a genius.
It doesn't count david seaman,
our ladies and gentlemen.
Brian,
what do you got going on?
Did you have some dates coming up soon?
Uh,
this weekend,
uh,
I'm going to be in la jolla,
pop out doing a bunch of comedy shows,
rescuing alive live,
killed tony show friday and saturday at
the la jolla comedy story alive.
Have killed tony friday and saturday.
Just saturday,
friday and saturday we're doing just
comedy shows,
but saturday we're doing also at killed
tony.
Oh,
okay.
What time is the kill tony?
A 6:00
call.
So you do a comedy show after that?
Six to eight is that we doing?
Yeah.
And if you buy a,
a ticket for the live podcast,
you get into the comedy ship for free
and it's at the comedy store,
which is one of the best clubs.
Definitely fucking awesome old school
club.
Yup.
And then the tickets just went on sale
also for me.
Tiffany haddish and tony in portland.
Seattle and vancouver.
Pow.
bitches got tv,
delicious and nutritious.
Uh,
I am going to be at grand prairie,
Texas outside of dallas on March 14th
with fear and duncan trussell were at
the verizon theater.
That's the day before the ufc in dallas.
Could be a good time.
Brian red band will be there.
If you want to kiss him and hug him,
he'll be there at the.
AT the ufc event.
Miami,
Florida.
I'm with tony hinchcliffe at the
fillmore on April 3rd and then orlando
on April 18th with mad flavor,
aka Joe Diaz and joe is also with me.
April 25th in baltimore and then I'll,
we'll be doing a lot of stuff I'm sure
in and around la in between now and then
tomorrow.
Brian callan and doug during and steve
rinella.
All the people that were involved in the
mediator episode which airs thursday
night.
A part one was last week,
part two is this thursday.
They're going to be on and.
Great guys,
especially doug.
You guys had never met doug,
but he's a guy who owns that farm in
Wisconsin.
He's a professional land manager and
just a really well educated gun.
A little weed.
Don't tell anybody.
He's a good dude.
Love him.
Uh,
so,
uh,
thanks to our sponsors.
Thanks to stamps.com.
Use the code word j r e and getting on
their delicious and nutritious.
One hundred and $10 bonus.
Offer that stamps.com.
Use the code word j r e and thanks also
to [inaudible] dot com.
it's o,
n n I t use the code word rogan and save
10 percent off any and all supplements.
We'll see you guys tomorrow.
And uh,
if you're in the hoya,
make sure you catch the big desk squad
show this weekend at the comedy store.
Like I sAid,
it's one of the coolest venues in the
country.
It's a dope old school club that's been
around.
Kennison used to perform there.
Man.
Fucking play has been around forever.
All right.
We love the fuck out of you and we'll
see you soon.
David seaman hour on itunes and stitcher
and the internet.
Anything else?
David?
Anything of the last message?
If you were the last moment on earth,
you have to say something and it's going
to be encapsulated and spread the future
generations so they won't make the same
mistake.
What would it be?
America is mostly doing it right.
We just got to fix the small parts and
uh,
I guess that's what I believe it with.
I would say get it together,
bitches,
and thanks for having me.
This is awesome.
And keep
it together,
bitches.
Yeah.
We have to do this more often than we
absolutely will.
All right.
Much love people.
See you soon.